後ろから見えますか？では
よろしくお願いします
少々真剣に聞かないと
ちょっとわかりにくくなる可能性もあります
ということは 今日のテーマはそんなに難しくはないんです
ですから 気をつけて聞かないと
私が言っていることは矛盾に聞こえるでしょ
それは逆です 皆様の思考は矛盾だからどうしようもないんです
まあとにかく損得ということについて話しています
で いわゆる我々はこれをどうやって評価するのかということで
はい あの損得を考えず生きていられないという
だから感情は必要でしょうかと
我々は生きている上で
損しているか得しているかということをね
考える必要あるのかとか
それは悪いのではないかとか思うかもしれませんけど
実は損得を考えず生きていられないんです
誰でも大体生きている上で損しているか得しているかっていうことを考えているんです
それでギブアンドテイクという
よくみんな一般的に言いますけどね
それは普遍的な法則なんです
世の中でギブアンドテイクっていうのは
で これは本当は言えばギブアンドテイクっていうのは仏教的な言葉ではないんです
だから仏教的でいえば
ギブアンドゲットにならなくちゃいけないんですけど
まあそれからその言葉を使います
それから人間に人間関係に限らず
物理の世界でも確実にある現象です
この出ていくことと入っていることっていうのは
もう人間だけの世界ではなくて
物を見たってもあることなんです
物質でも他の物質から何かもらって
自分から何か与えて そこで一緒になって合成して存在するんですよ
例えば地球が太陽に依存して
太陽が地球に まああんまりないんですけど
まあそうやってもう生きている
まあ存在しているんです
で 例えば鉄っていうのはもう一人だったらちょっと不安定だから
まあ酸化するでしょ 錆びちゃうで
錆びたところで安定するんですね
だからそこで鉄は酸化するということは
ギブアンドテイクの働きなんです
離れないんです お互いに
で 酸素から何か自分電子が自分の中に鉄の中に入ってるんだから
もう酸素には逃げて逃げられないんですね
それで酸素にしたっても
不安定な電子があるんだから
そこは何かに引っ越させておかないとうまくいかないんですよ
ですから このお互いにやりとりをやっても酸化する
鉄はもう錆びるということがあります
だから どんなものに見ても
そうやってこのお互いにもうあげて与えてというよね
それで関係持っているんです
だから人間だけこれ悪いと言ったっても何の意味もないんです
ただ もうすべてのものを見ても
そうやって物質さえもギブアンドテイクという機能で動いているんです
はい 与えて得る原理 摂理というのは仏教の因果法則の一部です
それから私が説明しようとしているのは
この これは宇宙の法則で
物質にさえもあることで
だから私たち人間にだけかっこつけてね
私はギブアンドテイクできていませんとかね
まあそんな欲張りじゃないんだよということはできないんです
で このギブアンドゲットという
いわゆる与えて得るということ
仏教の因果法則の中の一部です
はい 因果法則に見られるギブアンドテイクという与えて得るということ
えーと ちょっと数字で説明します
これは数学的な使っているシンボルは正しいかどうか分かりませんから
間違ったら石原さん教えてください
で  X X というのは人だと思ってください
ある人にはたくさんものがある
と Y という人にはそれほどものはないという状態で
その場合は たくさんある人から少ない人にあげるということは起こるんです
あげるとかいくということは
それから逆も起こるんですよ
たくさんある人は少ないところからもう受け取る
取ってもらうという 世の中ではいつでもあげるということは
たくさんある人がない人にあげるだけじゃないんですよ
たくさんある人は少ない
あまりない人からも奪ったりする
それちょっとわからないでしょ
金持ちはどうしても貧しい人から奪ってるんじゃないんですか？ですごい金ある会社の社長やらね
いろいろ工場の社長やらね
ものすごいたくさん取っているんです
で それでほんのちょっとでも労働者がちょっとちょっと仕事をサボったとか
ちょっと何かミスを犯したりすると
かなり罰金を与えたり
いろんなことをしたりして
また取っちゃうんですね
大体ある人はない人から取るということは
かなり世の中であるものなんです
ある人はない人にあげるということはほとんど少ないんです
だから普通頭だけで考えちゃうと
まあたくさんあるところからないところに行くのは普通ではない
それは頭だけの観念で
実はもう逆になってるんです
世界は人間の中では で
物質世界の中でも大体そういうことはまあ起きたりはする
例えば太陽にはすごい質量があるでしょうし
いくらでもものあるんだけど
地球は自分の方に引っ張らせているでしょうに
まあ地球も別にめげているもめげないんだから
まあ一応ぶつからないということになってますけど
だからその場合でも やっぱりたくさんある人が少ない人を引っ張ってます
我々は空を飛びたいんですけど
なかなか飛べないんですよ
なぜかというと 我々にも引力ありますよ
質量あるんだから でも地球の方があまりにも巨大にあるんだから
もうもうやられているんです
地球に引っ張られていて全然飛べないんです
だから世の中である普通はそれなんです
法則は だから Xという人でも物でもたくさん持っているのに Y
には少ないのに Yのものを奪ってしまうと
それは一つのやりとりの法則なんです
お母さんと子供の関係でいえば
お母さんはもうずっと与えるばっかりで
子供から何ももらわないということもないわけ
それは少ないんです そういうケースは
それすごく少ないんです
はい 次の そこでXとY
このXという人とYの人 2
人も同じ場合はどうなるのかと
それで2人一緒になる
合併する あるいは全くもう別れて離れるという
嫌だと そういうふうなのは
それもギブアンドテイクの関係なんです
では一緒にやりましょう
一緒に生きましょうということにはなる
まあ例えば 夫婦は二人でお金出して
まあ両方とも仕事をしているならば
二人でお金出してちょっと高い車を買うとかね
どちらでも同じお金あるんだから
二人夫婦はもうじゃあ半分半分出しましょうと出して
一人のお金だったら普通の安い車しか買えないんだと
だから二人でお金出し合って
結構いいものを買いますよということで
それでXプラスYになるんです
で 同じもので逃げるということは
例えばもうまあまあ あまり例は浮かびませんだけど
まあ例えば大学の研究室で二人の学生が同じ研究をする
二人ともすごく同じレベルの能力がある
一人を追い出さないと
もう一人の仕事はないんですよ
だから仕事っていうのは一人一人しかない
卒業してからは そうすると一人追い出すんです
追い出さなくたっても二人で考えるんですよ
二人はこの同じ大学にもしがみついていると
二人でもアウトで仕事はないんだよと
だから他の大学も調べましょうと
言ってどこかどこかに
その場合はもう反発して出て行くということなんで
別にいつでも喧嘩して悪いことっていうわけじゃないです
常にまああることなんです
例えば兄弟のケースで
小さい時はすっごい仲良くでしょうに
一緒に寝るでしょうに
これでどんどん大きくなっちゃうと
もうものすごく喧嘩して別れて別々に生活する
だからって兄弟が仲が悪いわけじゃないんです
例えばお姉ちゃんの部屋でいつでも弟がいるかもしれません
でも二人とも大きくなるんだから
そんなに年の差はないんだから
大きくなっちゃってもうお姉ちゃんの部屋が嫌やと弟も言うし
弟は入るなよと弟を追い出す出すでしょうし
お姉ちゃんは その場合でも X イコール Y なんです
弟君もお姉ちゃんもだいたい同じ力で
もう出て行けということで別れるんですね
もう必ずしも喧嘩する悪いっていう意味でもなくて
それは自然法則です はい
そこで X に小さなプラス書いてます X
に何か余分にあるんです Y
という人には何か欠けてるんですね
で  X という人に何か余分なものがあって
それがY という人に欠けている
その場合は X から Y がそれもらっちゃうんですね
まあそれも例で考えればもう簡単です
二人はどこか もう二人がどこかへ
まあもう出かけた で じゃあ弁当持って行きましょうと
まあ一人は弁当と飲み物
お茶とか全部持って行った
もう一人はまあそこら辺で買えないんではないかということで
弁当だけ持って行った
旅をしたところで お茶買うところはない
それでそれが Yさんの場合
弁当はあるんだけど お茶はない
X さんの場合は弁当もあってお茶もある
それでどうせ当たり前の結果として
X さんが Y さんにお茶を分けてあげなくちゃいけないんですよ
まあそれぐらいの話で
まあ数字で書けばなんかすごい難しく感じるかもしれませんだけど
だいたいそんなもんです
Give and Take っていうのは
はい 次 それで X と Y の関係の場合は
あるいはもう二つ結合して別なものになるということもあります
人間の例で言えばね なかなか難しいんですけど
お坊さんの世界ではよく見られます
よくと言ったっても 出家したのはお坊さんで
ちゃんと出家したいという修行をしたいということで
そこで全くのもう別な Y という世間の誰かと仲良くなる
例えば芸術家か音楽家かもう政治家が誰かと
仲良くなっちゃうと 政治家か音楽家は自分の考え方
生き方はものすごくしつこく
このお坊さんに言ったりするし
お坊さんも自分の生き方や考え方をしつこく相手に言っちゃうし
やがてどちらどちらでしょうかとわからなくない状態になっちゃうんです
お坊さんなのにいろいろ芸術活動したりもするし
政治家なのに説教もしたりするしという
まあどうにもならん状態にもなります
人間の世界では大体そうやって結合するということもあります
それも give And Take なんです
物質の世界ではもう単純なことなんですけど
はい そこで give And Get の場合は
X これで X マイナス A と Y マイナス B ということを考えましょう
Give And Take というのは
X から何か A 何かなくなるんですよ
それで Y からも何かなくなるんです
まあこれ難しいんだったらコンビニで考えてください
お金を持って行って弁当買おうとコンビニに行く
行ったら自分持ってるお金が必ずなくなるんですよ
それでコンビニにある弁当 1個もまたなくなるんですよ
だからXっていうのは自分だったら
Aっていうのはお金になるんです
Yっていうのはコンビニだったら
Bっていうのは弁当になるんです
そうすると この二人からも何かがなくなるんです
なくなってXがBをもらうんです
YからなくなったものをXがもらう
だからコンビニに行った私が
コンビニにある弁当を私がもらいます
そこでコンビニの方が私持っているお金をもらいます
で それが普通のギブアンドテイクというギブアンドゲットという働きなんです
だから それ成り立つためには
私に何か欠けてないとダメなんです
あるいは私は何かを欠けないと損しないとダメなんです
なぜ損するのかというと
向こうにある何かを私が必要としているんです
それで交換ということになるんです
それで損得っていうのは
A 等しくはない  B に その場合は損したか得したかという問題が出てくるんです
自分が 600円で弁当を買ったんですけど
隣のコンビニちょっと顔を出したところで
同じ弁当ももう 450円だと
特売日で そうすると損しちゃったと思うでしょうね
だから 自分からなくなるものと
その代わりに自分が受けるものが等しくない場合は
損か得かということは成り立つんです
それも比較できる時だけ
隣のコンビニに顔を出さなかったら
別に損でも得でもなんでもないんです
その場合は まあこの弁当は 600円だよと値段はもう落ち着いているんです
隣のコンビニもちょっと顔を出したところで
そのコンビニは特売日にやっちゃって
同じ弁当を 450円で売っているということを見たならば
損しましたと 今日はということになってしまう
だから損得っていうのは
まあ余計な比較するときだけ成り立つんです
はい これがまあではあり
まあこれからそんなに
それわかればもう簡単です
話は ですから 認められるしかありません
私たちにはすごく穏やかな生き方はできません
あの損得の生き方 与えれる生き方しかできないんですよ
だから美しい人間関係とか何とかとか考えない方がいいんです
人が自分の周りに寄っているんだったら
これを何かを自分から得るためなんです
自分も仲良くしているのは
何か向こう側から得るためなんです
だからそれはもう自然法則で
何も関係ないんだったら
もう全くの関係ないことになるんです
決してカラスなんかは来て
自分の肩に座ったり もうかわいい
もうもうかわいく顔を見せたりはしないでしょうね
もうあっち行けという感じでしょうね
その場合はもう何も得るものも与えるものもないし
だから関係なくなっちゃうんです
損得のシステムを理解する
だから我々は損得のシステムを理解するしか
もうどうしようもないんです
で 損をしない生き方を選ぶ
当たり前なんですね 損ばっかりしちゃうと
自分から欠けるだけでもう自分壊れてしまいますから
やっぱり やっぱり損しない方が正しいんですよ
しかし 悪の道を避ける
だからといって 何だかんだもどんな方法でも自分が得するようにしようと思っちゃうと
全てなくなってしまうんです
それで崩れます システムが
数学と同じなんです 決まりがあるんだから
決まり破ることはできないんです
好き勝手に だからこの悪の道を避ける方が損をしない正しい生き方に改良する
自分が損をしない また悪をも避けた正しい生き方
それに自分の生き方を改良するんです
それがやり方なんです
はい 次 それで この損得の世界を理解していない方の得点
損得なんかには無関心で無知で生きているとこういうことになります
自分のことしか考えられない
自我中心になってしまいます
私は損得なんかは考えませんと言っても
結局は自我中心な人間になってしまうんです
自分のことしか考えられなくなっちゃうんです
他人とうまく付き合えないんです
損得には無関心だったら
人とうまく付き合うこともできなくなるんです
こう親子関係が崩れるのはその時なんですね
大体は 損得のこと関係なく
親がもう自分の好みで
もう勝手で 子供のためやと思っても
いろいろあれこれと与えようとする
勝手に強引に でもそうは成り立たない
与えるということは 得るということによって成り立つんだから成り立たんし
だからそれで崩れたりするんですね
それから他を不信に思う
他人のことをあまり信頼しないことになります
疑うことになるんです
損得を考えないと これが得手になります
それから自信喪失 懐疑心
引っ込み そういうものも期待できます
だからそれはもう 説明しなくてもいいとは思いますけどね
だから自分が損するか得するかということは全く無関心で
あれこれでやっちゃうと
やがて懐疑心になっちゃうんですよ
疲れてなんでこんなことをやらなくちゃいかんですかとか
もうやっていられないんだとかね
ということになりますし
自信もなくなっちゃうし
引っ込み状態にもなります
騙されやすい 真面目に損得を考えないとも簡単に騙されるでしょう
だって自分のことしか考えてないんだから
これは素晴らしい品物です
言って ああ そうですか
では買いますということですぐなるんです
もうちょっといろいろそこの外の世界は考えないんだから
得るものはほとんどなく
損だけの人生になる 損得考えない人っていうのは
得るものない 得るって難しいんですよ
簡単じゃないんです それにまあ曖昧でいい加減で生きてると得るものなくなっちゃうんです
しかし なくなるものっていうのは簡単になくなるんですよ
それっていうのはもうまた普通なんです
では 皆様のお金もそうでしょうに
得るのはどれほど難しいかと
でもなくなると思ったら簡単になくなるんだから
簡単になくなっちゃう
だからかなり気をつけないと
得るということは難しいんです
それにもういい加減な人っていうのは
損ばっかりするのは決まっているんです
ですから 損だけの人生になるんです
それはもう得点とか言ったら冗談で書いたんですけど
理解しないと損得の感情は理解しない人はそういうことにもなります
はい 次 で理解している方の特徴
損得を理解しちゃうと
他人の気持ちもよく理解できる
自我を張らない人間になる
で 損するか得するかということをよく理解するということは
相手のことを理解するということなんです
相手の状態も だから自我を張ってわがままでいると
相手の相手方の状況は理解できないんです
だから人間の世界で生きている場合は
まあ自分が損しているか
得しているか 相手の相手に対して考えるでしょうに
だから相手の気持ちも理解するいい人間になります
それから他人に好かれる
よく損得を考えて行動する人っていうのは
結構人に好かれますよ
気に入られます その人は有効的な生き方をするんだから
まあ有効っていうのはまあまあ効率的という意味でもあるし
有効的っていう意味もあります
だからこのどちらにしても有効的な生き方をするんですよ
だから好かれるんですよ
みんなもうその人なら大丈夫だと
迷惑じゃないんだと 今日も
例えば自分から何か取ろうと来ても
その人知ってますよ そう簡単に取れませんよと
何かしてあげなくちゃいけないんだと知ってるんだから
それを何かをしてくれるんですよ
ですから 何か取るつもりで来ても
こちら側がその人のことは好きになるんです
だって何かをしてくれるんだから
せっかくそういうことをやってくれたんだから
では もう君はこれ狙ってきたでしょ
じゃあ持っていってくださいって言うんです
それで嫌な関係は成り立たないんです
ですから 損得感情をちゃんと理解する人が結構人気者にはなります
他は自分を騙そうとしない
これ成り立ちません 騙しはなくなるんです
もう他人がね まあ騙そう騙そうということをしないんです
なぜかというと 騙せなくなっても
その人はその損得感情で考えているんだから
もうちゃんと理解しているんだからね
騙して騙してなんとかするっていうことまではいかないんです
騙しにくいんです それから
財地人の 3つで得をする
損得感情がある人が 財っていうのは財産のこと
金 金やらね そういう物質的なこと
これでもちゃんと得をします
それから 知っていうのは知識
知る世界ですね それでも結構得をするんです
それから人っていうのは人間関係ですね 3
つのところで得をするんです
というわけで 本当に損得感情っていうのはよくわかっておいた方が結構いいものなんです
人生は人格向上を趣く
ちゃんとこの損得ことっていうのは
これから説明しますけど
ちゃんと考える人っていうのは
やっぱり良い良い人間になれなければ得しないんだよということをよく知っているんです
そういうことで 悪人になればなるほど得はしないんです
だからこの人 損得勘定をしているんだから
得をしたいでしょうに
だから自動的に人格向上するんです
人に優しく 親切に落ち着いてとかね
いろいろ得をする道 人格向上の道も選ぶんです
はい それでテーマ変えます
次に行きます そこであの一つの基本的な理解ですね
で 基本的な理解 それで終わって次のところに入ります
第2章に損得法則の理解へと
この法則を理解しましょう
これからは で 損得はものに限らずという
まあ書いたんですけど
この損得っていうのは大体一般的に考えているもののことじゃないんです
お金が損しました お金が得しました
そういうくだらんことじゃないんですよ
人にまあ千五百円の花束を贈ったところで
その人をお返しとして
あのもう 1万円の何かプレゼントをくれたとか
得しましたとかね そういうくだらんものだけじゃない
そんなもんじゃないんですよ
損得っていうのは 大体知識の損得あるでしょうし
テクノロジーのノウハウの損得はあるでしょうし
人格の損得はあるでしょうし
例えば いい人間なのに悪い仲間と一緒に行っちゃうと
その人すごく損するでしょう
人格的には だからあらゆる損得はあります
全部考えてほしい ただ
金のことだけじゃないんです
で それからこのバリューローデッドということで
このまあなかなか日本訳できなくて
評価を載せた単語ですね
で 我々は日常生活で使っている言葉のこと
そこでも損得勘定 いろんな感情的にいろいろ表れます
損得を表す単語が 使う人の評価
感情によって変わるのです
なんかわけわからない日本語なんですけど
我々単語使うでしょうに
損したか得したかという
その単語の中に言ってる人の感情が入ってるんです
単語のいくつかを読んでみましょう
それを読んでみるとわかります
私が何を言おうとしているのかと
自分から出ていく情報やもの
それはアウトプットなんですね
自分から出ていくもの
自分が受ける情報やものっていうのはインプットなんですね
として 2種類になります
大体誰もあまりアウトプット
インプットということは使わないんですけど
そういう単語を使う人々にも感情があるんですね
すごくクールで物事を見ているということで
はい それでアウトプット
自分から出ている方あげるということ
で ニュートラル まあそれほど価値が上げる
送る 提供する 発表する
手放すとかね あまり感情はないんで
手放したとかね まあ上げたとかね
それはとても中間的なんですね
ポジティブ ポジティブ的な場合は布施をする
いいことをしましたという感じで評価しているんです
与えるという時も評価しているので
言っている本人が それで寄付する
寄付しましたと ちょっと胸張るでしょうに
その場合はもう勝ち得てるんです
いいことをしたんだそうと
それで手放したということとはちょっと違う
手放しもちょっと嫌な気持ちが入ってますけど
で それから援助する それも評価的な言葉なんですね
支援 応援するというね
助言するとかね それでも与えるという意味なんですよ
全部あげるという意味なんです
あげるという意味で これぐらい単語あるんですよ
それでネガティブ もう否定的な単語というと
まき散らす 放言する 垂れ流す
押し付ける 押し付けることも与えることなんですよ
でももうそれだけでもとんでもないことをやっているんだというね
意味が入っているんです
で 攻撃する 攻撃するっていうことも与えることなんです
でも我々はこれはとんでもないというふうに思っちゃうんですね
それから漏洩するとかね
そういう風に このあげる
与えるということにも
日本語にしたっても これいろいろ様々な単語があるんです
その単語によって人の感情が表してるんです
ですから 今日のテーマも別に親父ギャグということでね
感情っていうのは 2つ同じ漢字使ってます
感情とは漢字だけ変えて使ってますから
だから損得勘定の場合は人の感情も入ってるんだって
これはあげる場合は では
受ける場合はどうなるんでしょうかと
受ける場合ね もらう場合
ただ受ける もらうということなんですけど
ニュートラルのまあ中間的な価値ない場合は
もらう 獲得する 支出する
取り入れる 収集するという言葉は使えるかもしれません
すごく評価する場合は
受け入れる 学び取る 結構かっこいい言葉で使ってるんです
それから拝聴する 次は何でしたっけ？承諾
え？承諾する いただく
頂戴する 歓迎するとかね
全てもらうという意味なんですよ
もらうという意味なんですけど
結構 2 2行目は評価が入ってます
いいことやってるんだと
上の場合は まあまあ普通普通なことをやっているんだそうと
下の 3行目では悪いことをやっているんだという意味になっちゃうんです
自分がもらっているのに
悪いことをやっているんだと
例えば奪い取る 盗む 搾取する
むさぼる かき集めるとかね
消耗は与える 消耗されるっていう与える時には使わないですよ
受け取る時には使わない
消耗  消耗してくださいっていう風に
そうですか つまらないものを贈りますよっていうことですから
あ そう 向こうの人がに対して言う言葉で
だから消耗してくださいって受け取ってくださいっていうでしょ
そう つまらないものあげるからね
うん だけどこの場合は受けるばかりだから
自分の方では使わないんですよ
消耗するっていうことはそういう言い方はないんですよ
微妙ですけどね うん とにかく私はあまり知ってる言葉ではありません
使いませんしね  そんなもんで
ただ 私は言いたいのは
そういう日常生活でっていうのは
もっとたくさんの言葉があるかもしれません
我々は日常生活っていうのは
いつでももらう あげる
もらう あげる生き方をしているんだから
たくさん単語があるんです
当然 そもそもなんでたくさん単語があるかというと
私たちの感情で評価して
区別しているだけ もらうのはいつでもありがたいわけじゃないんですよ
借中は悪いと思ってるんだから
それももらうことなんですけど
そういう風に使っている言葉によって
いいことか悪いことかと判断しちゃうんです
それぐらいの話です そんなに難しいことではございません
じゃあ 次に行きます それからちょっとポイントは難しいかもしれません
それで生きるということは何なのかというと
ものは受けてあげて 受けてあげてっていうことなんです
それは物質の世界でも起こるんですよ
生を受ける時点から死を迎える時点まで
生きるとはインプットアウトプットの流れなのです
これが理解していただければ
もうもう話す それ以上話す必要はないんです
生きるということはすごい簡単な定義できます
いろんなものを入れる
入れながら またいろんなものを出す
外へ それだけの流れなんです
呼吸見たって もうずっと受け入れて外へ出す
酸素を入れて二酸化炭素を出す
また酸素を入れて二酸化炭素を出すと
それで生きているというでしょうね
ご飯食べたりして そこで体力として使って
それは外へ出す 何だかんでももうそうやって一部を取って一部を捨てる
一部を取って一部を捨てる
一部を取って一部を捨てるという
これ この交差点に自分と名付けています
ただ 物事を交換する交差点ですよ
こちらは この交差点にあ
自分 私と偉そうに名前つけてるだけ
ただの物質 だけではなくて
いろんなものが流れる交差点なんだ
自分というのは 結局は自分とは何の実体もない
存在価値もない一時的な点一つなのです
点というのは存在しないんだからね
頭の中ですが 数学的に知っているでしょうね
点の数字っていうのは
直線と直線を何て言うんですか？ミーティングポイント
交差するところは点と言うでしょうね
点は存在しない あ これは点じゃないんです
大きいんです 面積があるんです
面積があると点じゃないんです
だから直線というのは絶対描けないんですよ
数学とかやっていますけど
まあだから頭の中で存在するんであって
実際は存在しないんです
例えば直線書きましょうとかね
でもどれぐらい細いかと決めなくちゃあかん
そうそう それでは直線じゃなくて
何て言いますか 面になって
そうすると細長い四角のような長方形になるだけ
だから長方形を描いて線というんだからとんでもないんですよ
だから線は描けないし
点は存在しないし 観念だけ
そこで自分というものも
ただ物事を与えてあげる
与えてあげるという交差点だけ
単なる一点であって だから何のない存在価値がないんですよ
私がすごい立派な人間やとかなんとかとか
なんでそう思うのかとわけもわからないんですよ
それただ与える あげる
もらう もうその働きだけなんですよ
時々与えるものはもういいものを出て行っちゃうと
私ってすごい立派だよと言うんでしょうし
例えばもう何か小説とかなんとかくだらんことを書いて
それはバカ売れになっちゃうと
あ 立派な人やとか いろいろなんとか賞
なんとか賞とか触れたりして
それで有名人 立派になったりすると
何の意味もないんです
そんなのは 何か外へ出すだけなんです
本人の妄想は そこは受けてしまっちゃえば
自分にはすごい人格者だと
人格があるんだと 例えば自分がくだらんことをいっぱい妄想して
文章を書いて本にして印刷するでしょ
それでもうものすごく売れると
それであらゆるところで報道されて
報告ももう紹介されちゃって
秋田なんとか賞やら直木賞
秋田川賞やら もうありったけのいろいろ賞をもらったりするとかね
あるいはノーベル賞までももらったりするかも
それで本人がすごい偉い人間やと偉い勘違いするんです
ただ出て行ったものによりだけの話なんですよ
もう何もないっていうのは仏教の立場なんです
ただの交差点 ノーベル賞までもらう小説家でいたっても
あっちこっちからいろんな情報をかき集めて
それをまた出すんです
それだけの話です だから芸術活動でも文学活動でも
科学的な活動でも 発明家でもなんだかんだも
ただ生きているんだということは
受け入れて 外へ出す 受け入れ
外へ出すという機能しかしていないんです
だから昔はね このどこかで空いてるところで
人間っていうのはあのブスブス交換していたでしょ
こんなすごい立派なスーパーデパートあったわけじゃないでしょうに
木の下とかね あるいはちょっと空いてるところで
自分が作ったものを持っていって
そちらへ それで別の人々が来て
自分を作ったものを持って
だからじゃあではこれで分けてこれもらいますと
これでこれもらうと ブスブスこれでまた家に戻るでしょうね
あの場所というのはすごい立派ですかね
ただの交差点だけだから
で 私っていうのはその木の下の場所なんです
そちらにすごい価値あるものをブスブス交換するならば
もうただ有名になるんです
あちらに行けばいいもの手に入るぞと
でも その場所になんの価値もないんです
だから生きるということは
そういうブスブス交換ということなんです
それが理解できれば もう結構いいものですよ
存在って何なのかと いろんなものの出入りするところです
それだけ だから自我がないんだと
別に存在で何の価値もないんだと
だからそんなくよくよして
そんなに自我を張って
は損したらどうしようかとかね
悔しいとかね 何が悔しいんですか？すごい気楽に穏やかでいられますけど
まあそこはまあ一応まだあります
交差点ということは 人生とは流れの交差点
そこに執着して喜ぶ意味も
嫌になって悲しくなる意味も
真剣に損得を考えて悩んだり困ったりするべき意味もありません
人生には これやってるでしょ
だから無知というんです
ただの交差点なのに これでまあ喜ぶ
何に喜ぶんですかね 通訳したり
嫌になって悲しんだりする
何に悲しんでるんですかね
例えば 木の下であるおじいさんが若い豚を １匹連れてきたんだと
それでまた他のおばさんがちょっと布を １枚持ってきたんだと
２３メートルぐらいは
おじいさんがこの３メートルの布切れは欲しいんですけど
でもあんた何かこれなきゃあげんぞって言ったら
しょうがないんだから豚をあげちゃう
それで豚でこれはちょっと損しましたとかね
なんで悔しいですかとかね
そういうふうに思う必要はないでしょうし
人だったらそう思いますけど
その場所はね 自分でその場所だから
この場所っていうのは本当にとんでもない場所だと言えますかね
関係ないです その場所には
その木の下のところには
２メートルの布１枚に豚が出入りしたんだからといっていても
場所にとっては何の関係もないんです
豚に交換しようか 馬一頭に交換しようかと知ったもんじゃないんですよ
もうその場所で 私っていうのはその場所だからね
ブスブス交換の だからそういうことをするなよという
だから明るく元気で その真理を知った人が
因果法則を知った人はすごい穏やかにいるんだということを
そういうところにある意味なんです
はい まあそれでまあ難しいところはありますが
これ第３章に入ります
まあ一応本を読んでいるような感じなんですけど
しかし 損得は無視できないというタイトルなんです
前はあんなことを言ってもね
やっぱり交差点だから
まあ冷静で平気でいましょうと言っても
私たちはそれでもやっぱり無視できん状態にいるんですね
無知だから 理性だから
理性的な生き方といえば
損はしない生き方になります
そういうことで 私たちはどう生きていればいいかといえば
理性的に生きましょうと
というのは 損をしない生き方なんです
それであの これはもうタイトルです
この章のテーマです はい
1つです 愚者は垂れ流し生き方をする
それで頭が悪い人々の生き方ってどういう生き方かと
損得の判断もできず まず頭が悪いんだから
損得の判断はできない
感情の制御ももうですね
もうできず それもできない
感情でやられちゃうということもあり
チャレンジ精神もない
まあ怖いだからやめたとかね
いろいろもうチャレンジっていうこともない
運命にすべて任せ 散ったようなふり
をして 愚者は損のみの損のみをする
生き方をする する二つはいいということですね
愚者の生き方は それはもう良くないということはわかるでしょう
大体損得の判断は必要なんです
例えば豚が子豚がいて
自分があの2メートルの布切れも欲しいし
これでブスブス交換しちゃうと
まあ損するでしょうし
だからこれいろいろいろいろやりとりやらなくちゃいけないんですよ
もう一つのやりとり その場合もありますよ
あるおばさんが2メートルの布切れ一つ持って
あるおじさんが子豚を 1匹持っていて
その場所で交換しようとしちゃうと
これ損するんですね それでそちらにまた他の人も来るでしょうに
もう一人の人が来る その人はまた別な品物
例えば 5個ぐらい持っている
椅子一つとか机一つとか
あるいは枕とか まあ何でもいいんですよ
ブスブス交換だから そこで話し合って
あんたはね そのおばさんにその枕をあげて
あの布もらってくださいと
これ交換でしょ それで枕の価値と 2 メートルの布の価値はほぼ同じだから
じゃあいいでしょうと
そこで枕の代わりに枕がおばさんがもらって
おばさんが布にできる
あの人にあげる そうすると
この豚 1匹持ってきたらね
君はこれ 3つ私にくださいと
で 豚もらってくださいと
ということで  3 つの中にあの 2 メートルの布切れが入っているんです
それで損してないでしょうに
だから ちゃんと損得勘定をしていろいろ工夫して生活する意思はありますけど
それをやらないんですよ
人間というのはもう 正しく
それから感情が出てくると
もうどうにもならない
もう全くもうとんでもない判断する
それからチャレンジというものも必要なんです
生きるためには 大体本当に損するか得するかわからない時もあるでしょうに
それでもやってみるんだということも必要でしょうに
そこでまあ 私は別にそんなことは気にしないんだよと
損得なんかはもう何ままですかって
流れるままで生きてるんだぞとか
それはものすごい無知な人の言い方なんです
なんかすごい なんか文学的にすごい立派な生き方やと思うでしょ？気が向いたまま歩くとか
気が向いて何でまたえ？何？風
風の向こうは気の向こう
そうそう 風の向こうは気の向くままとかね
あんなのは正真正銘の愚者の生き方なんです
文学的な評価も何もないんです
それはやってはいけないんです
計画を立てていってほしい
このだらしない このこの昔のね
あの国の状況が悪くて
食べるものもなくなったりとかね
戦争とあったりとかね
それでみんな逃げ回ったり
夜逃げしたり 出家したりして
それでもやることがないんだからね
風の向くままにとか それは負け犬の考え方であまり私は評価しないんです
何も物を持たなかった
悟ったお釈迦様も風の向くままに歩いたわけじゃないんです
今日はあの町に行くそうと
比丘たちお前らも準備して一緒に来いと
そういうふうな生き方をしていったんだから
だから最高の賢者さえも風の向くままには生きていなかったんです
大体これでこの運命にすべて任せてっていうのはとんでもない生き方なんですよ
それで悪いのは この知ったようなふりをするんですよ
ああいう文章を書いた人やら
ああいうふうな浪人的な生き方をした何々浪人とかいるでしょうね
すごい立派やと本人も思ってるでしょうね
おそらく 我々思ったってしょうがないんですけど
もしかすると本人もそういう気取りでいるでしょうと思いますけど
私だったらバカにするんです
で 愚者はだから損のみをする生き方をするんです
結局何もない だからお釈迦様は全然損していないんだから
あの町で行って  3ヶ月つっかみて
では出かけるぞと別なところに行く
その信者さんが知らないお釈迦様はどこへ行くのかと
またいつ戻ってくるのかと
でもお釈迦様は次はあの町に行く
次はあの村に行く あの人に会う
あの川で沐浴をするとかね
ちゃんともうそれなりに計算してする
だからお釈迦様は損していないんです
行く行くところ みんな仏教を理解する
修行して悟りも開く だからこのただただの浮浪者ではなかったんで
出家ですけど 何も物を持たなかったんですけど
浮浪者じゃないんです
しっかりと計画的に動いて
結果は出して涅槃に入るんです
でも その結果 自分に対しては別に何の関係もね
もう悟ってるんだから
結果は自分にとってどうでもいいんです
しかし 無駄な生き方はしない
それは愚者の生き方 それから次
それで智者の智者は正しく勘定する
これ 智者っていうのは皆様のことなんですけど
普通の人々のこと これを正しく勘定する
自分にとって損は何か
得は何かと知り 自分にとって真理を知る人のアドバイスを常に受け受けて
真理 事実知ってる人のアドバイスもちゃんと受けて
感情を制御し 自分にも他人にも迷惑のない
特に溢れる有意義な生き方をする
それは智者の生き方 だからこの生き方を目指さなくちゃいけないんです
ちゃんと計画通りに生きる
知らないことをちゃんと知ってる人々から調べて知る
それだけでは足りません
人に迷惑はかけない 損はしない
得ばっかりする生き方なんで
だからといって人に迷惑はかけない
そうすることで生き方は有意義になるんですよ
無駄にならないんです
たとえ悟り開いて一切煩悩なくなっても
生き方自体は有意義なんです
だから一般の普通の知識的な人々は
こういう生き方はしなくちゃいけないんです
はい それで賢者のこと
それで賢者っていうのはもう悟ったこと
人のもう悟り 完全に悟り開いた人の場合は
賢者は損得を乗り越えて生きる
智者はちゃんと損得勘定をする
愚者はもうああいう生き方をする
賢者は損得を乗り越えて生きて生きる
損に悩まず 得に惑わず
一切に執着せず 清らかで完全たる自由な心で
勝利者として賢者は生きる
それが賢者の生き方 それで悟った人だけ
損得はあまり考えないんですけど
だからといって馬鹿な生き方はしません
だから損が起きても 別にまあただの交差点だから
まあまあそんな気にするもんかって
全然気にしない それで得をする
当然得ばっかりする だからといってどうったことないんではないかと
ある場所であの薄く ものすごいダイヤ
宝石を交換されても もう腐っているものを交換されたっても
肥料とかね 豚やら犬をどうでもいいでしょう
その場所にとっては だからそこはまあ一切執着せず生きてるんです
それで清らかで 心が で
完全な自由な心 完全たる自由
損得に引っかかっちゃうと自由じゃないんです
損得っていうのは必ずも勘定しなくちゃあかんだけど
それがある限り人は自由じゃないんです
例えば両親 子供は可愛いなと思っている限りは自由じゃないんですよ
もう子供から離れなくなっちゃうんです
いえ 可愛くない 憎たらしいと思ったら自由になりますか？自由になれないんです
それでもそれで依存するんだから
だから憎たらしいと思うことも評価でしょうし
感情でしょうし だから損得勘定する限りは
心は自由じゃない だから賢者だけ損得勘定はしない
だから心は完全に自由なんです
はい 今日早く終わろうとしてるんです
知識人の道 いわゆる理性のある人の道
これからこの智者の生き方を説明します
これは皆様の役に立つと思います
賢者の生き方はちょっと置いておきます
いきなり賢者になるんじゃなくて
僕 俗人でいいんです 損得勘定して
まあ困ったのはそれもできないところなんです
だからまあ その生き方
損得の勘定をしなくてはならない
しっかりと我々は損得勘定をしなくちゃいけないんです
家計簿っていうのも まあ家計簿でお金だけなんですけど
人生の家計簿をちゃんとつけなくちゃいけないんです
よって 正しい価値判断の能力を身につける
で 価値判断を正しくしなくちゃいけないんですね
注意深く生きる 注意しなきゃ損するんですよ
だからいつでもこれだったら損するのか得するのか
それをずっと気をつけないと
子供にこんなこと言ったら本当に損するのか得するのかと
それ注意してないでしょうに
お母さんたちがギャーギャーギャーギャーって言いたいこと言っちゃうでしょうに
だからそれ与えてますよ
でもしかし それを押しつけるんですね
悪い与え方なんです だから
結果として悪い結果になるで
それが母親にとって損でしょうに
だから子供に対してもギャーギャーと言う前に
こんなことで自分が損するのかと考えてもらわないと
得するのか損するのかと考えてもらわないと
正しくは生きていられません
だから 旦那と結構喧嘩する時でも
ただ単にいきなりキャーキャーと喧嘩するんじゃなくて
それで何か損するのか得するのかと考えて行動すれば
だから常に注意しなくちゃいけない
ただ 店で時々は品物を束ねて
もう 3個いっぺんに買うとこれぐらい
10個いっぺんにこれこれぐらいとか
値段下げて売るでしょうに
あ これ安い いきなり飛んで買うでしょうね
でもよく考えれば損しているんです
1個 1個 5 5個買う場合は
1個の値段かける 5かもしれませんだけど
5個まとめて買うと あの
ほんのちょっと 10%
15%で 20%引いてるかもしれません
問題はその品物は 5個自分に必要なのかと
持ちますかと 時々品物って賞味期限というものもありますからね
せっかく欲張って買ったのに
それからは隣の奥さんにも
隣の隣の奥さんにも配る羽目にもなります
人にあげることは悪くはないんだけど
この特売で安く買ったものは配るともう見え見えでしょうに
もういらんことを買って
ただもう自分がもう手放してるだけではないかという
だから受ける側も それもらう側も
すごくありがたく感謝してもらうということはなくなるでしょうに
だからすごい損なんです
もし隣の奥さんに何かあげたければ
それなりの価値あるものは大事に買って
これは差し上げますということをした方が
それで得する 損しないんですよ
私のことよく思っているんだと
その方は思いますからね
いきなりバカみたく感情でパーッと買い
買ったものはもう使えなくなっちゃうし
早くも賞味期限切れちゃうし
だからもうバラまいまき散らしちゃっても
損だけするんです そういうわけで
人生の中で我々は常に
気をつけなくちゃいけない
注意深く ただ飛び込んでいっただけで得するわけじゃないんです
だから 一人一人の人間が自分の人生の経営士にならなくてはならない
これはもう避けられない
例えば 仏教はなんでさんざんいろんなことを喋るかというと
これは人生の経営学なんです
それは全ての人間が勉強しなくちゃいけないんです
だって あなたのために私は生けてやりますということは成り立たんでしょうに
自分が生きてなくちゃいけないでしょうに
全く無意味なことだったら
人のためにやることはできますよ
じゃあご飯作ってあげますとかね
どうってことないことはできますよ
あなたのために喜んであげますとか
そういう成り立たないんです
だからあなたのために生きてあげますということはなりません
それぞれ人は個人個人で生きるんだから
だから すべての生命は自分の経理士にならなくちゃいけないんです
はい やっとその 第3章終わりました
経理士にならなくちゃいけないというところで
では 会計学の授業を始めます
お釈迦様 まあこれから普通の知識人として人生をね
ちゃんと勘定するとの学問的なものなんです
ですから それはどういうことかとちょっと勉強してみましょう
で まずもうまあまあ授業だからね
大学でもこのあの 3 年間これこれやるぞというね
あの その項目内容はまず本にして出すでしょ
それは英語でプロスペクトって言うんです
で だからこの概要プロスペクトはね
まず 1 は何を勘定する？これ内容
人生勘定するんだといって
我々はお金の勘定しか考えてないんだから
それでは足りませんだからね
それはたった 1個だけ
勘定するべきものはものすごいたくさんあります
だから内容 2番目 この鑑定の仕方
評価する方法  3番目 正しい見積もり書と誤算
これ狂っちゃうとダメだからね
それから損を避ける方法
4番目  5番目 倒産しないための秘訣
まあだからこう まあ大学の授業スケジュールに書いちゃったんだから
これ 1年ぐらいかかると思います
ちゃんと実践するためには
だから項目を言うだけで終わっちゃうんです
かなり量が多いんです
一応このあの 5つでこれから説明します
と覚えておいてください
はい 次に行きます  1番目
何を勘定するという授業なんです
勘定する場合は  1 物 物っていうのはお金やら家やらね
うちの家はあの人の家よりはすごく立派であるとか
それも物の勘定なんですね
2番目は知識 情報などはですね
3番目は人間関係 我々は人間で生きているんだから
人間関係もちゃんと勘定しなくちゃいけない
損しているか得しているかと
4番目は人格発展 進化のために私は発展という言葉ではなくて
進化という言葉を使うんだからね
で 進化のために必要な情報
知識ということ それちょっと難しいんですけど
いわゆる道徳と真理なんです
それで我々は感情するときは自分を進化させなくちゃいけないんです
生きる場合は 毎日良い人間に進化しなくちゃいけないんです
で それには勘定しないと
これだったら進化する
これだったら退化する
取り返してもらわないと
そうするとこの道徳なんですね
道徳をちゃんと守ると
自分が人間として人格はどんどん向上する
それが真理があるんですよ
真理っていうのは本当のこと
事実 それ知ると人間として進化するんです
悟れるんです だからそこまで勘定しなくちゃいけないんです
だから皆様 普通の学校に行って高いお金を払って勉強する感情というのは
ただお金の計算だけ 会社の経理だけのことなんです
ほんのわずかなんです
それもすごくややこしいでしょうし
だからこの方がものすごいややこしいんです
かなり時間がかかります
やるそれ まあ一応大雑把で概要だけ
ポイントだけ言います
それで我々は生きている上で何を勘定するべきかというと
まずものを まあそれは誰でもやってますね
で 例えば外国行きたければ
やっぱり夏はやめましょうと
高いんだからとかね 思ってるでしょうに
オフシーズンだったら空港券は半額以下ですよとかね
そうやって勘定するんでしょう
それはものの勘定悪くないんですよ
それをやらなきゃ損するし
2番目は知識なんですね
だから いらん知識入れちゃうと人はダメになるでしょうに
間違った情報を考えちゃうとダメになるでしょうに
どうしても言いたい 一つ間違った情報があって
言いたいんですよ これが
イライラするんで言わないと
で で イラクという国を潰しちゃって
アメリカとイギリス人とまたもう腰抜けのいくつかの国々がね
まとめて まあ潰したのはアメリカ
それからイギリス軍隊ですけど
他の連中はただ何も軍事力を持ってないんですけど
ただまあ何か落ちたものを拾って食べるぞという感じで
あの田んぼを畑を耕す時は
カラスやらサギという鳥やらずっと群がってるでしょ
別に仕事を助けてくれるわけじゃないんです
何か上へ出てくるミミズやら
それ食べたいんですよ
でも食べるとくちばしでこちょこちょこちょ刺すんだから
それは田んぼにとってはありがたいことで
それでアメリカとイギリス軍隊にそうやって応援で軍隊
まあそれぐらいの仕事なんですけど
行って潰してからいきなり看板変えるんです
イラクを復興するために来ましたと
テロを根絶するために来たんだと
看板かで私は知りたいのは
イラク人がいっそテロをやったんでしょうかと
アメリカに対して イギリスに対して
いっそでしょうかと 一つのケースはないんですよ
それで看板を変えると
世間の人々はやっぱりテロはダメだ
根絶しなくちゃあかんだと
だったらテロを潰せばいいでしょうに
どこかの国を潰したっても
それはテロの根絶になるんじゃなくて
新しいテロが生まれるだけでしょうに
でもキャーキャーキャーキャーとマスコミでニュースで
このこの ABC やらね
もうものすごい極端に歪曲して歪曲して
もうデータなデータではなくて
作ったデータを流す それから次に看板変える
復興するそう えらいかっこつけて
我々はイラク人の国民の復興のために頑張ってるんだと
みんな鵜呑みにするでしょうね
イラク人の復興したの誰ですかね
イラク人の家でも病院でも何でも潰したの誰ですかね
潰して復興してまた格好つけられる
それで看板変えたんです
それでまたみんな乗るんです
では復興に行きましょうと
それで日本にもいる一般的な NGO やら
普通の若者やらね もう一人勝手に行動する自由な思考を持っている人々いるでしょうね
流れに入らない この愚か者の流れに
そこで勝手に行っていろいろボランティアやったり
イラク人と一緒にご飯食べたり
一緒に苦しんだり 一緒に悩んだり
いろいろやったりはする
で 最初 復興というならば
それは復興でしょ そこで腹が立っているイラク人がこの戦略者を潰したり
ぶん殴ったりする そんなのは当たり前のことだから
そうすると突然イラク人はまたテロにする
とんでもない人々だと
テロ活動しているんだと
それで次のステップは一般人が出ていけと
我々軍隊で十分やと だから復興するんだったら
一般人が援助を 援助を行かないと復興できんでしょうに
だから復興はもう取り消し
これからはさらに殺してやるぞという話なんですけど
それでせっかく前の看板に載せられて復興に行った人々はみんな非国民なんです
日本人でも一般人と一緒に復興運動をやっていたでしょうね
ボランティアとか とんでもない人間なんです
国に迷惑をかけるんだと
という話なんですね だからどこで理屈はあるのか
どこで事実あるのかと
よくも全くもいい加減なことを突然看板変える
でも店は同じものなんです
だから我々はこの情報でもね
ただ垂れ流してる情報をそのまま入れちゃうと
頭の理性がなくなるんですね
私はいつでも定義で聞くんです
テロって何なのかと あんた方はちゃんと定義しているのかと
この提供している情報っていうのは
ちゃんと裏付けをつけているのかと
ただガチャガチャ言ってる感情なのか
どちらかと そうやってみないと頭が悪くなるんです
それは一つのいい例なんです
もうなんかイラクに一般人が行くことは
今 悪 悪行義で こうなんて悪いことでしょうね
テロを応援するために行くんだと
そこまで言うんです 今まで謳った復興運動ってどこに行ったんですか？それ自体もヘリクツですけど
だからそういう風に もう世界っていうのは我々を騙してカモにしたいんですよ
自分の利益にも人類がバカになってもいいんです
誰かの利益のために だからそういうことをできているのは
我々は情報も勘定しないんだからなんです
だからお釈迦様は革命者だから
一人一人自分で情報勘定をしなさいと
自分の耳に入ってくる情報は本当にそのまま正しいか
あるいは無視するべきか
あるいは真面目に考えるべきものかと
きちんと勘定しなさいと
これを聞くと損するそうと思ったものは聞いてはいけないんです
これ聞いちゃうと得するそうというものは聞いてほしいんです
だから 立派な人間に生きるためには
この情報の勘定もすごい大事なんです
それで知識もありますね
何でも知っていいわけじゃないんですよ
皆様が一生懸命 もうすごい簡単単純ですよ
例えば原子爆弾をどう作るのかとかね
あの毒薬はどう作るのかというのはとても簡単ですよ
だって人間に体にいいものっていうのはすごい少ないでしょうに
世の中で食べて健康になるものっていうのは本当に少ないんです
他はほとんど毒だから
それはあれやこれやとか
まあいい加減に好き勝手に合成して出しちゃえば人は死ぬんです
だからといって 簡単だからといって
科学的な化学的な研究だからといって
そういうものは研究してはならないんです
教えとするんだったら
その教授を追い出した方がいいんです
だから仏教は情報化 の場合は
こういう毒作るごと武器作るごと
商売にもしてはいけないんだと
禁止しているんです ですから
個人個人で自分が知識だから何でもいい
ありがたやではないんです
ありがたくない知識もあります
精神的にもいかれてしまっておかしくなる知識もあります
そういうものは入れないようにしなくちゃいけない
だから情報の勘定も損得で損するか得するかで見なくちゃいけない
人間関係も人間関係の場合はかなり勘定しないと
人は誰でもいいというわけじゃないんですよ
仲良くするためには 自分に損をする人だったら
もう追っ払った方がいいんです
人間と付き合う場合でも
人間だったらたくさん友達がいた方がいいとかね
いればいるほどありがたいのではないかという
それはとんでもない話なんです
自分にとって損するならば
その人付き合いは切った方がいいんです
自分にとってすごくいいことをしてくれる人だったら
すごくその人としっかりとベッタリして仲良くした方がいいんです
だから 人間関係について仏教は結構うるさいんです
よくよく言うのは 人っていうのはどうせわがままだから
この出家者に言うんですよ
あんたはね 全く一人で生活しなさいと
そこまで言うんです 全くの一人で
なぜかというと 人間っていうのは所詮わがままで自己中やと
だから この この もうこの
何て言いますか 文学的に考えて
ちょっと感情的に考えて
たくさんの人々と付き合っているんだそうとか
友達がもういくらでもいるんだそうとか
そんな威張ったもんじゃないんです
だから 人間関係もちゃんと損得勘定に入れるんです
それから人格のことはまあ置いておきます
次に行きます それで内容に入ります
2番目 で 感情の仕方 何を感情するかというと
これは それは授業あったんです
それからどのように勘定するのかという
まず優先順位をつけてみます
感情の優先順位といえば
一番大事なのは人格の発展
向上なんです これは理解していないと思いますけど
金儲けより大事なのは人格者になることなんです
より立派な人間になることなんです
それは絶対優先第 1 なんです
2番目 道徳なんです 人格的にはそれほど優れてなくたっても
道徳を守っていなくちゃね
世間に迷惑をかけないで
嘘つかないで 泥棒しないで
人を騙さないで 詐欺を詐欺をやらないで
道徳的な生き方をしなくちゃいけない
それは 2番目の優先なんです
3番目は人間関係なんです
人間には一人では生きていられないんです
誰か誰かと仲良くしなくちゃ生きていられないんです
しかし それ 3番目なんです
4番目は知識なんです
知識もあっていいものであって
知識なくても生きていられますよ
だから順番は低くしたんです
時々知識があって生きづらい場合もあります
だから世の中は知識は素晴らしいと言うんですけど
そうではないんです 一番下モノなんです
モノというのはお金 マイホーム
車とかね ブランドのカバンとか
そんなもの もの これが優先順位です
仏教の学 経理学では 会計学では
だから人はこちらで鑑定する方法を勉強していくんです
その順番に はい 次に行きます
鑑定の仕方は 2番目 必要性を重視した順
あの順番と逆になるんです
必要性で考えちゃうと
1番目はものなんです
面白いでしょう なぜ？食べ物は 1番でしょうに
どちらにしたっても それものでしょうに
必要性で見ると順番が逆さまになるんです
それ何に必要かというと
生命を維持するためというわけでね
すべて生きて上の話ですからね
悟ることまでも生きた上の話ですから
そうするとものは 1に来るんです
それはみんな賛成だと思います
それしか能がないんだから
もう儲かるかないかということしか
しかし 損ばっかりしているでしょうに
それで 2番目は人間関係
もうご飯食べたっても
やっぱり全く一人でできるわけじゃないし
いろいろ人間関係を成り立たすし
で 家族は必要でしょうし
だから 2番目の必要なのは人間関係なんです
家族は 2番目に必要です
一番目に必要なのは食べ物なんです
次 家族なんです それから知識
3番目なんです 知識もあったらありがたいことで
もうこれは簡単に生きていられます
4番目になるんですね
道徳は 必要性から見ると
だって泥棒したっても生きていられるでしょうに
不正働いてでも金儲かるでしょうに
そういうことだから 人間っていうのは
これ人間 そういう順番をつくるんです
必要性があって しかし
仏教は逆の順番をしているんです
これは皆さんも当たり前だと思いますよ
誰でも どちらにしたっても食べ物は先ですよと
生きている上ではそういうものなんです
それから家族やら友達が必要になるんであって
それでその関係をうまくいくためには知識は必要であって
で それからなんですね
道徳なんか真理なんかは
大体誰でも社会ではね
道徳なんかはもう全部もう後回しでしょうに
杖を着てようが永久的に出てこない
道徳は大事やと もう学校でも言ってはいけない話でしょうに
学校っていうのは悪人工場と言った方がいいみたいですね
本当に立派な人間が生まれてくるんですけど
みんなもう世界に迷惑を
悪人に作ってくれるんだから
悪人工場みたいなもんですけど
だから事実知りなさいと学校で教えないんです
嘘ばっかり教えてるんです
日本の教科書はもうずっと改良ばっかりでしょうに
それでも真面目には事実書かないんです
だからそんなことを歴史で言ったっても
嘘ばっかりで教えたりしてね
まあ数学ぐらいでしょう
数学も仏教の道理から見ればもう成り立たぬものなんですけど
だから結局は人格は教えないんですね
道徳を教えない 真理を教えない
なくても大丈夫やと ただ鬼みたいに競争して勉強しなさいと
それどうなるかというと
わかったもんじゃないんだと
はい しかし問題っていうのは
こういう順番をつけたんだけど
これはネットワークで繋げているんです
だからしかし この必要性には優先順位はない
常にどちらでも必要なのです
だからこれは俗世間の順番ですが
それも無視できない 生きるために人間そういう順番をつけています
それで仏教からお釈迦様が言うのは
この 4つは Why で考えてくださいと
例えば Why と書いて
これ 4つに分ければいいんです
こういう風に 全部つなげているんです
どちらでも必要なんです
一つ抜けちゃうと もう壊れちゃうんです
だから道徳が抜けちゃうともうダメでしょ
人生は生きていられなくなるでしょう
人殺したりでもしちゃうと
で 知識がなくても生きていられますけど
全く知識がないとそう立派には生きていられないんですね
だからまあ 4つも同じレベルで大事だと思った方がいいんです
だから優先順位はつけないんです
はい 次に行きます そこでまた 3番目
この感情の仕方 これからはもう優先順位つけたでしょ？それから必要順位つけたでしょ
それにこういうやり方で感情するんです
得たから与える 得るために与える
得るなら与える いらないから与える
与えるという 5つあります
で 感情っていうのは与えてもらうことだからね
それでみんな忘れているのは
これ これから説明しますけど
もらうことを先にするんです
それは成り立たないんです
あげてからもらうんです
だからあげるものは自分持っているんだから感情できますよ
変な人々はもらうものの評価先にするんです
自分持ってないんだから
それ評価感情できないんです
だから自分から出すもの
マイナスするものはどれぐらい価値あるのかという感情しなくちゃいけない
ですから まあ与えることなんですけど
ある人々は得たから与えるというやり方を取るんですよ
もらったんだから その分なんとか返ししましょうと
あんまりかっこ悪いんです
あまりよくないんです
得るために与える なんかちょっとずるがたいですね
3番目は得るなら与えるという
ちょっと態度でっかいんですね
うまくいくはずがないんです
いらないから与えると
世界っていうのはなんかもうゴミ処理場と思っているんですね
そういう人もうまくいかないんです
で  5番目はどういう意味でしょうかね
与えるだけっていうのは何もなく
これが知識人の関係ないです
これは賢者の世界で 賢者の世界では 5番目です
与える 得るという概念ないんです
だから皆様にはそれは理解できないと思います
我々理解できるのは 何かあげて何かもらうという世界なんです
それが上の 4つなんですけど
これどちらか考えたって
なんかちょっと変でしょ？だからそういう感情はちょっと勉強しなくちゃいけないんです
得たから与えると言っちゃうとね
もう世界が親切でないと可哀想やと
この人はと思うなら生きていられないんですよ
だから世間任せなんです
もしそんな人のこと心配しない社会でいると死んじゃいますよ
得たから与えるということだったら
だから 1 もうまくいかない
2 はずるがすこい  3 はなんかもう態度でかい
もう潰されます  4 は人を世界は馬鹿にしているんで
自分のいらんものは全部処分するだけのことで
だからお返しはもらわないんです
いらないものをくれたんだから
相手に だからどうすればいいんですかね
はい 得る与えるシステムで人生は成り立っているので
それはまず理解してほしい
とにかくあんなものは 5つ書いたんですけど
まあ一番一つは 5番目はもう我々に関係ない悟った人のことで
4つもなんか質が悪いんでしょうし
しかし 得る与えるシステムで人生は成り立っている
前言った 5項目の 2 を改良して使用するのです
あの 2 番目改良するんです
2番目何なのかというと
得るために与えるのではなく
与えて得る 美徳です 得るために与えるんじゃないんです
与えて得る それが仏教的なんです
そんなに難しくないんですよ
そういう生き方が正しいんです
あの 4つをちょっとやめた方がいいんです
世間ではその 4つしかないんです
だから仏教的な人は 4つも捨てる
前説明したこの 23枚目の再度説明した 4つも捨てる
捨てて 2番目改良する
2番目は得るために与えるという難しくやり方でしょうね
それは鋭いやり方です
それは与えて得る すごく冷静です
それで間違いではありません
それで道徳を守られます
それから 後の与えるという道は到達点になるのです
与えるだけ  5番目は悟った人の生き方なんです
そこは自分の到達点なんです
今は一応与えているということするんです
与えている 与えている
じわじわと得ることは減らしてもらって
与えるだけになるんです
それはもうこれからじわじわと成長していけばいいんです
そこまでは与えて得るという生き方をしなくちゃいけないんです
はい それで結論ですけど
与えては得るという生き方をする
与えるという生き方になるまで上達するという
それは感情の仕方なんです
一つの結論が出て またありますから進みます
それから感情だから この価値の問題が出てきますね
与えるものの価値は得る人にある
意味がわかりますかね
与えるものの価値は得る人にあります
例えば すごい単純で考えてください
とにかくこの難しいことを考える場合は
この小学生のレベルで考えてほしいんです
そうすると ものすごい難しいことを考えられます
で 私はご飯 2合炊いたりする
私は 2合食べられません
料理できないと見るんですね
私はその人にも半分分けてあげる
それでその価値が私にあるわけじゃないんです
料理できない人が美味しいものを作ってもらって
ああ よかった そちらで価値を入れるんです
与えるものに自分では価値はつけないんです
だから どれぐらい価値があるかっていうことは
もらった人が理解するものなんです
それはものすごく覚えてほしいんですよ
これは厳密なもう感情論なんです
遊びでもないんです ものすごい真剣な
もうなかなかこれだけまとめて書けば博士取れますよ
大学で学ぶ仏教学部だったら
これはとにかくこの時間の中で説明
全部説明します そういうものは論文形式で書く場合はすごい大量にデータ必要
必要ですからね それでこの
まあ例えばお母さんが自分のネックレスを娘にあげる
でお母さんにとってはもう結婚式でもらったものやとかね
当時でこれは 20万円になったとかね
なかなか大変な そんなのは価値入れたって意味がないんです
で もらった娘さんが価値入れるんです
もらった娘さんから見れば
こんなもう豪華なネックレスというのは
今買おうとすれば もう軽々こう ５０0万になりますよとかね
あるいは これはなかなかもうクラシック的なもので
もうどんな時代でもつけられるものだよというふうな
このすごく舞い上がるほど喜ぶ感じるんだったら価値があるんです
それで娘さんがお母さんから例えば 500万円のネックレスをもらう
もらうと こんな太くて
これはダサいんだよと
今更誰もこんなアクセサリーつけませんよと思っちゃうと価値がないんです
だから物の価値っていうのはもらう人によりなんです
だから板切れでも巨大な価値がある場合あるんです
普通はもうもうもうあまりちょっと大きすぎて薪にも使えない
お風呂を焚く時はね まあここら辺では薪で焼かないはないんですけど
まあちょっと田舎に行けばもうありますからね
そこであの窯にも薪の大きさは決まってますからね
これが大きくても もう小さくしなきゃ薪どうしても使えないんだよ
いや 価値がないんだよという
板一つあるとします それでもすごい価値がある場合ある
ジャータカ物語があります
この菩薩がある生まれで生まれて
商人として生まれて 大金儲からなくちゃいけないんだということで
友達 誰か知り合いの人々と一緒に船に乗って商売に行くんです
そこでその船がもう ひどい
あの 何て言いますか 嵐に遭遇して遭難する
どうせ菩薩だから 頭がそれなりに結構鋭いんだからね
で さっさともう全部捨てちゃって
まあ船からもう板一つ取っちゃって
それでもって海に飛び込むんです
飛び込んで 板に胸を支えてもらって
まあ浮いてるんです で
浮いて あの 水の流れがありますから
この流れに入って流れてもらってるんです
そうしちゃうと また流れに流されているもう一人の人を見つかるんです
その人はもうバカだから
板一つで持ってきていないんです
潰れた船から で 菩薩は考えるんです
この人は長持ちはしない
死ぬ しかし 私はもう菩薩になろうと修行しようと
この商売するのは まあただちょっとしたことで
しかし 私の本職はまあパーラミタという波羅蜜を完成して悟ることなんです
で 俗世間の儲かるということはこんなものにもなりますということで
で 今はチャンスやと 自分のパーラミタ完成するために
しかし ただ単にこの板切れ二人乗りはできんし
あくまで言ったっても
この人はね これはありえないことだから
どう思うかわからないんだと
だからこの人 何か私を助けてくれたことがあれば
それを言い訳にしてこの板をあげられますと
だけど 自分がもう途中で溺れて死ぬということをわかってますけどね
それで思い出すんです
この人の人生を 何も菩薩にしてくれたことはないんですよ
何一つも 困ったなと でもしかし
1個だけ思い出したんです
どこかで旅で そしたらすごい性格悪い人なんです
で 菩薩とも一緒に行って
で この人はかなりこの 3人分ぐらいご飯持っていったんです
菩薩はもう突然出ただけで何も持ってない
それで 1 日歩いてご飯食べる
普通だったら一緒にどうっていうのは普通なんです
インド文化でもスリランカ文化でも大体はあげるんです
すごくもうお腹が空いていて
でも一緒にどうっていうことはなくて
弁当自分で開けて もう一人分ぐらい食べて
残りはまた畳んでまた
じゃあ行きましょうと
それは何のことなく行く
またご飯食べることになりました
だからかなりお腹が空いてるでしょう
その時も自分の分食べて
残りをまた畳んで持っていく
それだけじゃないんです
インドではこのご飯食べてから口直しにというか
この何かあの噛むんです
それはいろんなものあります
結構豪華なものもありまして
この小さな葉っぱがあります
その葉っぱにいろんなものをつけて
それを噛む 噛んだら口がすごくなんか爽やかな気分になります
口当たり それで脳にも信号行くんだから
頭もすごくしっかりするんです
これも贅沢なんです インドでは
自分の国だったらいっぱいありますけど
インドになってくると贅沢で輸入しなくちゃいけないんです
その葉っぱとか この人はご飯食べてそれも噛んでるんです
で 菩薩はもうあれはもう贅沢と言ったっても
まあ別に金かかるものでもないし
もう自分が喉が渇いてお腹が空いて
もうものすごいヘタヘタ状態で
自分でお願いしたんです
この葉っぱ 1枚か半分ぐらいでもくれないかと
それで口だけでもなんとか脳が動き出すんだから
それで元気になるんだからね
葉っぱ 1枚というと ちょっと嫌な顔を見て半分あげたんですね
半分が全く足らないんです
半分あげたっても それにまたつけるものがありますから
それと一緒でないと意味がないんです
葉っぱだけは少々辛いだけで
その機能はしないんです
葉っぱの半分だけあげたんだ
それぐらいわがままなんです
この人は そこであの海の中で溺れ死ぬところでこれを思い出したんですね
この人は私にあの葉っぱの半分くれたことがあります
それでその人にあんたはね
そこに泳ぎ込みできないし
溺れるでしょうと 私はあなたにお世話になっているんだと
かなり昔 前 こういう旅に出た時は
私はあなたにお願いしたところ
あんたは葉っぱの半分私にくれたんだと
だから私は恩返ししなくちゃいけないんだよって
あの板きれをあんたこれ使ってくださいと渡しちゃうんです
だから それは菩薩の生き方で
これは一般人にできることではないんです
ですから この板切れっていうのは普通は何の価値もないでしょう
では 遭難している場合は
海の中で価値は何なのかと
命と同じ価値でしょうに
だからあの人はもしかすると
まあただ板きれではないかと
一応どこかに陸上に上がった時でも
あの人を馬鹿にするかもしれませんだけど
そういう悪人の生き方をはっきり示すために書いている一人です
でも正しく計算するならば
菩薩は板切れあげたわけじゃないんです
あれ  1円もならないんだよとかね
そんなこと言えるんですかね
だからもらった人が何をもらったかというと
命 です だから物の価値っていうのは受ける側にあるんです
どんなものでも その場合は菩薩も命あげますけど
まあそういう計算になりませんだけど
大体あの あなたに 10万円もあげたんではないか
あなたにはもうもう １００万円もあげたんではないかとか
そういうふうに言うのはけしからん生き方なんです
自分の与えるものは自分が判断するんだから
それは正しい感情じゃないんです
10万円もあげているのに
その人は随分もう気にしない
そんなことはもうもうもう助けてくれたことにもしていないならば
本当は助けてくれてないんです
まあ普通の人間だったら
悪人だったら別ですけど
話は だから価値が受ける側で成立するんです
受ける側するんじゃなくて
そちらで成立するんです
だから あの 私はそこらへん考えますけど
いつでも私に手紙来ると
ものすごいお金くれ お金くれっていう手紙ばっかりです
すごく腹が立つんです
何の役にもない ただの贅沢
無駄遣いするためのものなんです
それでもどこかから私の名前住所を調べてもらって
知らない人からでも手紙来たら
その手紙に 例えば自分がこういう学校で勉強しているんですけど
授業料を払えない 払わなくなったんだからとかね
あるいはこういうこういう本を買いたがっているんだよとかね
ということを言う その時要求するのはほとんどもう 1 万ぐらい
1 万以下ぐらいのお金なんです
その場合は瞬時に他の仕事でもやめて送るんです
なぜかというと その人にはそれはすごく役に立つんです
学生に勉強しなさい 塾にお金払いなさいと 10万
1万円あげたら その人はそれはもしかすると半年分の授業料かもしれません
それで勉強して得るものの価値はどうでしょうかと
一緒の価値でしょうに
だからたった 1 万でしょうということじゃないんです
家がかっこよく作りたかったんですけど
お金がなくなったと それで誰からもう 500 万くれないかと
大金でしょうに ではしょうがない
人を助けなくちゃいけないからといって 500 万あげたところで
その人は玄関に新しいドアが付けたぐらいとか
ちょっとちょっとなんかどこか直しただけでしょ
そんなに価値がないんです
それなくたっても生きていられるし
だから物の価値はそういうふうに
この受ける側で成立する
客観的な価値観 世間の受ける側に価値があるかないかは大事なポイントです
だから我々は与えるときは
この客観的な評価は置いた方がいいんです
この品物はこれぐらいの値段だとかね
店で高い店で買ったそうとかね
高い店で食べ物を買って
例えば私にくれたっても
私はあまり食べないものだったら価値がないんです
店は有名でしょうとかね
そういうことを世間はよくやるんです
でもそうやってこの有名な店で買ったとかね
普段は １００円ですけど
あのデパートではもうこれは 1,200円だよとかね
1,200円でリンゴを買ったっても
100円で買ったってリンゴはリンゴですけどね
味は少々形とかね 味よりもね
そういうことで それは客観的な世間の価値
だから世間の価値で見てはいけないんです
この人生感情するときははっきりと受ける側にはどれぐらいそれは機能するのかっていうところで考えるんです
それは仏教的な感情のやり方なんです
相場はこれぐらいだという時も
以上の条件は変わらない
それはちょっとわかりにくいと思います
これ私もよく言うんです
だから入れたんです 自分にできないことはいろんな人に頼むんですけど
値段付けると相場はこれぐらいでしょうと言うんです
向こうは高い値段を要求する場合は
で 相場はこれぐらいですよと言っても
その仕事は自分ではできないんです
だからといって向こうは決める
決める値段を払うことも
それで正しいわけでもないんです
とにかく相場はこれやと言った時でも
価値は受ける側には成り立つんです
具体的な例で言えば 今絵を描いてもらってますけど
その人はもう絵っていうのには値段つけられないという俗世間の考え方で
あれこれでゴニャゴニャゴニャゴニャ言うんです
私に個人的には それすごく怒ったんです
で 奥さんも来たんで 奥さんにも散々言ったんです
ものにはもう値段つける方法ありますよと
芸術作品だったらもう値段は決められません
だけど それはこの何と言いますか
このオークションするでしょ
オークションするときは
買う人が値段決めるようなものに価値がないんだ
あんた方にある人は 100万というかもしれません
ある人は 1万円でも嫌だよと言うかもしれませんよ
迷惑や そんな絵はと だからそういう風にもこれこれとぐちゃぐちゃ言うんじゃないんだと
もっとテクニック的に考えてくださいと
材料費とその人の能力とかかる時間と創作の使う
それとか それで考えると相場はこれぐらいだよ
と言ったら まあまあ それ以上は向こうは喋れませんだからね
ですから このだと言ったっても
私に負けるかというと
私には負けませんし 必要でないかと
そうでもないし 必要なことでもあるし
だからああいう風にものすごいビジネスライクにその場ばかりぐらいで言っても
やっぱりそれでも仏教の世界では価値は受ける側に成り立つものです
それは忘れません 私はあんなことを言っても忘れる
それは忘れはしない それもその人に説明はする
でもそれは別な話で この場合は成り立ちませんと
はい 与える人にも与えるものの価値がある場合は
得たものと比べて損か得か決められます
それは自分が与えるものには
自分にもいくらか価値があるんです
大体普通はもうどうしてもあげなくちゃいけないんですけど
ちょっとややこしいんですけどね
例えば弁当を買うことにしましょう
弁当を買う場合は もうこのお金が大事だ大事だということはないでしょうに
どうしてもそのお金を出さなくちゃいけないんです
もう自分のものじゃないんです
もう自分には弁当が必要ですからね
だからその場合はお金にそんな価値がないんです
出すものだから お金はどうでもいいんです
必要なのは弁当なんです
そこで弁当を買う場合は
このケースは成り立たないんです
ではなくて 自分の部屋にテレビがある
自分はあんまり見ない
友達が来てテレビがない
で テレビがないんですからね
もうあんた もうこれくれないかと
その代わりに何かあげますよと
はい 言うと自分はあまり見ないんだけど
時々は見る たまに それで自分にないのは
例えば何か他の 例えばその部屋で
あの なんて言いますか
リクライニングの横になる椅子がないとする
まあ別に必要というわけでもないし
ただ座ればいいんだからね
それで友達は私のところにこういうリクライニング椅子があるんですけど
それをあなたにあげます
それすごい楽だよと 座ったら昼寝もできますよと
ああ そうか しょうがない
テレビ持っていけと 言うと
その人はテレビを持っていて
あのリクライニングシートを持ってくる
なんかちょっと損したんじゃないかなと思う可能性あります
テレビはもしかすると 10万ぐらいかもしれません
リクライニングシートはもうもしかすると 1万 2万とかに
それでもそんなに使えないとかね
それであげたものはまだちょっと自分に必要なんですよ
まだちょっと自分に必要な時だけ
損したか得したかっていうことは成り立っちゃうんです
弁当買う時はもうお金は自分のものでもうないんですもん
とっくに だからこの損得っていうのは
その時だけ 私にもこれ必要ですけどっていう状態時なんです
で 常識的には損か得かと判断できないのです
普通はそれは判断できないものなんです
損か得かと だって自分が与えている世界だから
どうしても与えなくちゃいけないんですよ
得るものは自分に必要なんです
だから受ける側に価値があるんだから
だから損も得もないんです
ただ与えている世界だけなんです
本当は損得を考えない方がすごく楽なんです
考えないで与えてはいる世界であって
だから私はこれこれ与えて
これこれ得るのだと それでマーケットプライスでは考えちゃうとごちゃごちゃになるんです
はい 次に行きます あ 我々の損得勘定は異常なのです
これは異常です 一般的な世界でやっている損得勘定
勘定はとんでもないところで価値付けちゃうんです
それはすごく異常です
使いにくいカバンは 20万とか
あまりにも高いんだから物は入れてはいけないんですね
そこで買ったままで この袋のままで保存して保管しておくんです
そういうことって それは価値がないんですよ
何の価値もない そういう価値を入れると
それは異常です とにかくはい
次に行きます 得たものは自分にとって必要なものであるならば
それで十分なのです 自分が与えて得たものは
自分にとってはもう必要なものだったら
それで十分 損得かと考えない方がいいんです
もう得しているんです
なのに 得るために与えたものに対しても考える人はまだ非常識です
悩むことになるのです
何か与えてから これもらうために
私はこれこれぐらい これこれぐらい苦労しましたよとか
もう本当に大変でしたとか言っちゃうと
ただ悩みの種なんです
10年貯金してこの車買ったよと
たった 10年だよ  10年はない
1年も貯金しましたよと
結構結構いろいろ工夫したりとかね
食べ物のね 食べ物はずっと自分で作ったりとか
ベランダでも野菜作ったりとか
いろいろなことをして買ったぞとかね
それで儲かった気分にならなきゃ
何の意味もないんですよ
10年本当に苦労しました
もう二度とやりたくない
あんなのはと言っちゃうと
もう損しているんです
だからそこを 2行で書いたのはそれなんです
与えたものに対してごちゃごちゃ言うなよと
自分が何かもらいたいんだから与えたでしょうに
だから 10年もろくなものを食べないで貯金したっても
これでいいんじゃないんですかね
それで自分好きな車買ったんだから
もう得しているんです
悩むことになりますからね
それで得るために与えたものだから得たもので満足するのです
これはすごい大事なポイントなんです
経典には結構散々出ているんです
自分が与えたのは与えて得ることをだから与えなくちゃ得られませんだから
そこで得たもので満足しないと
あ 得てもらった 得てよかったと
あまりにも病気なんです
弁当を買って食べて まあフランス料理屋でご飯食べたかったとかね
あまりも変でしょうに
ご飯食べられてよかったというふうに満足しないと
今日は時間もなかったんだから
隣のコンビニで買いましたとかね
うまくいきましたと 今日の食事はと思わないと人生は不幸なんです
だから 与えて得たものには必ずも満足するべきなんです
これはもう常識です だって自分がわざわざと与えているんだから
満足するのは当たり前な
だから得たもので満足しなさいというブッダの言葉は大変な真理なんです
これがみんな誤解して
仏教は発展的じゃないんだと
これで満足しちゃうと発展がないんではないかとか言う人もいるんです
学者の方々は だから明らかに無知でしょうに
ブッダの深い真理を勉強してない
ただ表だけ読んでるだけ
パーリ語でサントッティというんですけど
仏教を始めるときでも
サントッティダンモと始まりますからね
異常な人にはできないんだと
サントッティやる人にはこの教えだよと
大変な教えなんです サントッティという満足するということ
得たもので満足する 当たり前のこと
ただでは得ることはできんだから与えているでしょうに
だから満足するしかないんですよ
はいはい それで最大を与えて
適量より生き方で満足できるのです
最大を与えるんです ケチってはいけないんです
得る場合は適量で得るんです
それ実行不可能だと思いますけどね
それ不可能じゃないんで
これがものすごい楽な生き方なんです
人が仕事を頼んだら 自分に頼むってこと
自分にできるってことでしょうに
その人にできないってことでしょうに
精一杯やってあげるんです
それで価値は受ける側するんでしょ？私はそこまでもやってもらうとかではなかったのも
ほんのちょっとだけでよかったんでは
本当にあんた ものすごい 100倍もうまくやってくれたんだよというふうにさせなくちゃいけないんです
これはすごいと受ける側は言わなくちゃいけない
だから相手がすごいと言えるように言わせるように自分が最大を与えなくちゃいけないんです
それの方がすごく楽しいんですよ
人生は 仕事も苦しくないんです
それで得るところは適量だけ
なぜかというと この必要ということというのは欲だから
欲にキリがないんですよ
絶対人間欲を満たしてはいけないんです
お金がいくら欲しいでしょうかと言ったってもキリがないでしょうに
だからこの欲を満たす生き方に
仏教を言ってるわけじゃないんです
欲にキリがない 欲望にもキリがない
怒りにもキリがない だからもう欲を満たすぞというのはもうとんでもない話なんです
いくらでもそれを膨張しますから
ではなくて 適量 なんですよ
お金がいくらあってもいいんだ
いくらあってもいいんじゃなくて
自分が豊かで幸せで生きるためには
まあこれぐらいあればいいやという適量を作っておかないと
この最小限のね これ 人間は最小限最小を与えて最大を期待する慢性的な受難症です
そういう病気もあります
それは医学者は発見しないんですけど
お釈迦様は発見しているんです
この受難症っていうことは
仏教でこの生きることは苦であるというのは
受難症のことなんです
別に苦じゃないんですよ
馬鹿だからあえて苦しんでるだけ
何これと だからこれは受難症というのは受難ですよ
それなんで受難するのかというと
最小を与えて最大を期待する
ろくな仕事もしていないのに給料を上げてほしいんです
で 文句を言うんで こんな給料で家も建てられませんよと
一生仕事をしたってのことと
逆に聞いて あんたどれぐらい仕事しているものかと
それだったら一生苦しいでしょうに
仕事はあまりよくないんだ
給料は少ないんだとかね
これで一生頑張っても昇格することも何もないんだとかね
だからこれは受難症ですよ
もう他の言葉がないんです
ありがたいことに 受難することはありがたいと言っているでしょう
ヨーロッパの方で ありがたいんです
受難症は 受難する仏教ぐらいあまり無知なんです
だから最大を与えて最小限ではないんです
適量をいただく 私はあえて最小と書いてないでしょうに
適量をいただく 私は相場っていうのはそういうことなんです
俗世間で言っている意味じゃないんです
それがこの損得勘定のやり方なんです
まだありますかね それでそのセクションは終わりました
損得勘定 勘定の仕方 で
3番目のタイトルなんですが
やはり見積もり書を書かなくちゃいけないでしょうね
それから誤算を避けなくちゃいけない
読むだけで読むといいますけど
得ることのみを考えると
見積もり書を作れません
得ること 得することばっかり考えちゃうと
人生の見積もり書にはなりたくないんです
与えてはいるんだから
それは欲はつけなくちゃいけない
あれ欲しい これ欲しいと思っちゃうと人生は終わり
ああなりたい こうなりたい
あれもやりたい これも買いたいとかね
だからお釈迦様はそういう欲的な生き方をやめなさいと言っているでしょうに
見積もり書を書けなくなっちゃうんです
欲しいと思えば もうもういくらでもあるんですよ
例えば世界を旅をしたい
歩き回りたいと これはキリがありますかね
一回行っただけで また 1 2
年経つと面白くなくなっちゃう
もう一度行きたくなる
だからどんなものにしたっても
欲しいと思っちゃうとキリがないんです
だから一回だけでもいいんだから
地球一回回ってみたいなというんだったら
もう一応いいんですよ
だからこの得ることだけ考えてはいけないんです
必要なものだからといっても
それが必ず得られるという理屈はありません
それから必要だから必要
みんな言うでしょうに
必要なわかってるんですけど
得られるかないかは別の話でしょうに
それだったら必要っていうのはちょっと削除しないと
だから必要必要っていうこともあまり真剣に考えてはいけないんです
必要性を最小限にする必要がある
必要っていうのはできるだけ最小限にする
例えばそれは出家世界にお釈迦様が教えているんです
病気になったら あなた方は牛の尿を飲んでください
どんな病気でも牛の尿で
それがで必須 なんて言いますか
最小限であると それであれば適量であって
満足しなさいと はっきり言うんです
薬っていうのは だからあのお医者さんに会いたい
あの病院で治療してもらいたいとかね
とんでもない話なんです
出家には  牛の尿ぐらいあれば十分だと
これで面白いこと 日本ではそれも手に入らないという
かなりきつい条件なんですけど
すごいお金払っちゃうんだけど
薬はない 飲んだらあかんという
とんでもないものもらっちゃう
牛の尿ぐらい飲めば体が治るのに
お釈迦様おっしゃったんだから
それだけでお釈迦様に対して敬意があって飲んじゃうと
もうたちまち治ります
それもそれでお釈迦様は次に言うんです
それでちょっとした塗り薬とか飲み薬とかね
もらったら あなたはものすごくもう儲かってるんだよと
もう余計に得しているんだよと思いなさい
着る服だったら そこら辺を捨てているものを持って縫い合わせで十分だと
それで満足しなさいと
もし信者さんもそういう模様とか何も入ってない
ちょっと布でもくれたら
あなたとんでもない儲かってるんだよと
すごいツイていることだと思いなさいと
食べるものだったら もう鉢を持って歩くと
人はいらんものを何かちょっとちょびちょびと入れるだけで
それで人は捨てたもんだから
あげた人は何の価値もないんです
また貸してちょうだいとは言わない
食べ物の場合は絶対言わない
だからそれで十分だと
もし誰かが食事でも作ってくれるんだったら
これとんでもない もうついてる
儲かってることである
住むところ一軒家とかとんでもない話を釈迦様が言うの
木の下であれば 木で枝で
それ屋根であればそれで十分
それで適量だよと だからそこら時点で
その一番最初の時点で満足するように教えているんです
だから俗世間でも我々はこの最小限ということを理解しない限りは
もう受難症は治りません
それで最小限で満足するんだから
もうちょっともらっちゃうとすごい楽しいでしょ
楽しく生きてられるんです
それで得るためには まず与えることでことは常識です
得るということを考えるんじゃなくて
与えるということをまず考える
だからミスマリ書を書く場合は
自分が何が与えられるのかということを考えるんです
はい 次に行きます 与えられるものは何かと優先に考える
それが誰に対して最大限に必要かと調べて
そちらに与える それで私が自分のミスマリ書を書くでしょ
私には与えられるものは何なのかとまず調べるんです
得るものじゃないんです
必要なものは最小限にしているんだから
これこれこれ与えられます
だからってみんなに与えたって意味がないんですよ
いらん人に与えたって
お金に そこで私が持っているこのものは誰にとって最大に必要かという
そちらに与えるんです
それで価値が大きくなるんです
自分が高価な薬を持ってるんだったら
そこら中に誰かに与えて何の意味もないんですよ
それで これが最大限に誰に必要かと考えちゃうと
その薬に関係ある病気を持っている人がいる
その上 その人にはその薬は手に入らない場合は
はい これどうぞと与える
それで その人には最大限に効果がある
価値がある それで自分に最小限のものをもらうということ
最小限ではなくて 適量ということ
それでうまくいくんです
メスも商売 それにしても
もう聞きたくない音楽を作って売ってるし
それで苦労してるんですよ
売れない 売れないとかね
競争は激しいとか 当たり前でしょう
優れたくて 私もいろいろ調べたんだけど
今インターネットあるんだから
サンプルリスニングするんですね
嫌って思っちゃうんです
これって音楽ですか？と
ジャガイモでも優れていたいんです
本当にもうひどい だから世の中そうやっていらんことを強引に押し売りするしかためになってるんです
なぜかというと このブッダのもうメス商法っていうのも書けないんだから
音楽でももう若者やら聴きたくてたまらん人々にとっては価値があって
聞きたくない人にとっては何の価値もない
どんなものでもそうやって価値っていうのは相手側から成り立つもので
それで  2番目行ったね
調べてそちらに与える
自分が得たいものは最小限よりも大きく得ているはずです
そうすると だから我々はこの最小限というか
この必要性を最小限にしているでしょうね
しかし 与えるものは最大に与えているでしょう
それで向こうからくれるでしょうね
くれるものは 自分が予測したものよりも必ず大きいんです
1万 2年でよかったのに
5万ももらったということになるんです
仏教的に生きているならば
私は 1万円でよかったのに
5万もらっちゃったんだよと
どうしようかと そういう豊かさの悩みは一人でもないでしょう
俗世間できる俗世間の価値で生きているんだからなんです
豊かな悩みは味わったことはない
普通だったらもうここまで仕事をしても
今日は 1 万しかもらって
だからこれでは生計は立てませんという話は普通です
こんな給料では生きていられませんよというのは普通でしょ
お釈迦様はそれは逆に変えたいんです
逆にしちゃうと逆で 私はそんなに怒らなくてもよかったのに
くれる給料で一部返したくなる気持ちなんです
そういう生き方ありますよ
確実に したがって必ず満足できるはずです
はい 次 以上の決まりが崩れると誤算になります
だから 俗世間の損得感情はすべて誤算です
主観的に得ることのみを考える
与えるものは何でしたっけ？俺はおろそかにする
強引に与えようとする
馬鹿馬鹿しいでしょう
与えるものをおろそかにしちゃうと
恩恵をもらうはずもないでしょうに
主観的に得ることばかり考えちゃうと
8万もらいたくて 家の庭の掃除でもしてあげましょうかと
はい お願いしますと言ったところで
あんたいくらあげればいい？ 100万ちょうだいと
誰がくれるんですかね
だからそうやって自分で額を先に決めちゃってうまくいかないんだ
そんなことみんなやってるんだから
もう誤算ばっかし 強引に与えようとする
音楽 芸術 映画とかね ダイエット食品とか
どれほどあるのかというと
どんな体に悪いものでも売りたければ
健康を考えてとか一言入れればもうバカ売れ
このもので健康となるとは書けないんです
健康志向とか体は大事とかなんとかとか
騙しちゃうんですね そうやっても強引に与えようとする
強引に得ようとする 満足度を知らず得ようとする
満足度を知らないと 得ても得ても不満なんです
これはもう これはまあゴールデンという言われる金庫なんです
覚えておけば はい 次 そこで 5番目
授業の最後 それでカリキュラムは全部終わります
で 倒産しないための秘訣
人生 これは人生なんです
会社ではないんです 他人に必要とされる生き方をする
与えるというのは人間関係だから
常に他人に必要とされる生き方をするんです
そうすると捨てられません
自分は 生命に対する慈しみ
生命のことを慈しみでいつでも思ってくれる
思う そうすると捨てられないんです
捨てたことで倒産だから
もらわないんだから 与える生き方を重視して
それによって人格向上を目指す
それから与えることがまず大事だと
それで与えることを中心にやりますと
得ても得られなくても
まあその場でいいんじゃないかと
もらわなかった場合は
それで自分が満足して
ちゃんと人格を向上すればいいんじゃないかと
だから与えたことでは必ずも得があるんだよと
与えたこと自体に 何かもらわなくても
それで自分がいい人間になるんではないか
それでいい人間になったっていうことは得しているんだ
そういうふうに考えるんです
人格向上を目指す 損得勘定にふける生き方の短所をする
この損得ばっかり考えてふけちゃうと
結構短所があるんです
これ知ってほしい これ短所です
損得勘定にふける生き方の短所をする
他人を侮辱する 侵害する
損得ばっかり考える人は
相手のことを侮辱しているんですよ
侵害しているんです その人からもらうんだから
もらうはずがないでしょうに
それで他人に損害を与える
自分が得したいのは当たり前でしょうに
その場合は そればっかり考えちゃうと他人に損害を与えるんです
自利のみを考えるわがままな人間になる
人になる 他人に優しい人間にはならない
損得ばっかり勘定すると優しい人間になりません
したがって 社会がその人を処分する
当たり前 だからこれ倒産するんです
損か得か 損か得かではなくて
何が与えるか 何が与えるかということを考えるべきなんです
それも誰に与えるのかと
それで簡単でしょうに
人生は それから生命に対する慈しみであれば
あの人からこれぐらい奪うぞと
あの人からこれぐらい奪うぞ
ないでしょうに そうするとみんな優しい人だと守ってあげましょうということになるでしょう
だから絶対倒産しない
これが秘訣です はい  6 損を避ける方法
人生 他人に対して自分には何ができるかという思考をモットーにして生きる
他人から取ろう取ろうではなくて
他人に対して自分に何ができるのかということがモットーですよ
結果として社会に必要な人間になる
与えるものは常に最大にする
自分が与えるものはいつでも最大にする
社会に 生命に役に立つ生き方であるならば
自分が自然に生かされていることになるのです
みんな口を上げて生かされているんだとかいうのは
あれは怠け者の考え方で
無知な人の考え方で この場合だけで使えるのは
他人に何が 私は他人に何をすればよろしいか
社会に 生命に 人間に何をすればよろしいかということはモットーで生計を立ててみる
で それで結果として必要な人間になる
必要な人間になったら
社会がその人を生かすんですよ
だから楽なんです 生かしてくれるんです
生かされてくれるんです
すごく楽々に あんたがなかったら困るぞと
あんたがいなかったら大変困るぞと
悲しいよというような生き方になるんです
その人には生きることは難しくはないんです
はい 早く終わりにしましょう
それで結論 ブッダの会計学の一切
至上に対して慈しみの気持ちで生き生き生きるならば
損得勘定に悩まなくても決して損をしない
得のみをする生き方ができる
これが結論です お釈迦様おっしゃっているのは
与える得る生き方ですが
得のみをする生き方なんです
損は全くもない 0 これが結論です
はい 次 幸福に生きることだけが能ではありません
輪廻転生する苦しみがあるから
限りなく注意深く生きる羽目になる
あのお釈迦様の水森翔生きてみたっても
ずっと注意深く生きていかなくちゃいけないんですよ
ちょっと失敗しちゃうと幸福を捨てちゃう
結構危険です あれでなぜかというと
生きていなくちゃいけないんだから
輪廻転生しながら完全たる落ち着きはありません
人格の進化を目指して
それに合格するものです
だから人格を向上させて悟りを得た方が最大の得です
最高な幸福です それこそ安定した落ちない
減らない幸福です 涅槃というのは
それを目指さなくちゃ
もう結構大変です いくらしっかり生きていたっても
ずっとしっかりしていなくちゃいけないんです
不注意になったところでも足が滑るんです
だいたい終わります それで後書きになりますけど
今まで喋ったことは何か仏教の話でないような感じがしますから
本当はこれすべて経典の中から取り出して
現代風な思考に編み込んだものなんで
なかなか大変難しいことなんです
で 経典では無駄遣い 酒
賭け事などに依存する生き方
不倫などは自己破壊になるから戒めているとかね
だからそこで教えているのはそういうところなんです
例えば 余計に無駄遣いすると
行くだけであって得るものはないんですよ
それで酒なんか使っちゃうと
もう瞬間の楽しみで体健康が壊れてしまって
すごいお金がいって得たものは何もないんです
酒飲んだんだからでバカになっただけある
ちょっとした時間はちょっとした時間
バカになったっても 経済的に何の意味もないでしょうに
だから仏教から見れば完全な損赤字の生き方なんです
酒は 美味しいとかなんとか言ったっても
行って頭の機能が減るで低下するでしょうに
頭の機能が低下すると経済活動できんでしょうに
それで酒にもお金かかるでしょうに
その上体の健康もなくなるでしょうに
どこらへんに得があるんでしょうかね
そういうことをやめなさいと
だからそれもちゃんと損得勘定でお釈迦様おっしゃっているものなんです
賭け事とかね 賭け事で大金儲かるそうとかありえないんです
そんなことあり得るんだったら賭け事成り立たないでしょうに
負けるんだから成り立ってますよ
欲もない行為したりとかね
損しかないんです 人間関係は絶対的な大事なものだと
特にそれから仏教はすごいうるさいんです
人間関係について それも損得の世界で教えているものなんです
損する人間関係をやめなさいよと
しかし 悪影響を与える仲間を敵のごとく遠ざかるべきだという人間関係
絶対大事だと言いながら
お釈迦様は悪影響を与える友達はもう敵だと
友達じゃないんだと 友達かぶれや避けなさいよというのです
それもそんとこの世界なんです
はい 採算の出入りでしたっけ？に注意すること
必ず貯金しておくことなども勧める
経典に書いてます いつでもこの採算がどれぐらい入るか
どれぐらいできるか いつでも勘定してほしいと
最近の人々は 両方気をつけてほしいと
それから貯金しなさい
って言ったっても 何でも貯金という話じゃないんです
適量に貯金する なぜかというと
人生が何が起こるかわからない
その時パッと使って借金しない生き方
借金は反対です ブッダは
すごく反対です お金借りることがね
あの投資は OK ですけど
それ以外はもう借金ものすごい
もうもう負け犬という感じ取っているんです
得たもので満足すればいいんです
だからそういう貯金のことも言っている
得ることなどは期待できない
期待できない貧しい人々にも適切に与えることをして
与えるのみのしきたりを身につける
そこで与えるのみという最大の徳があるんです
それは勉強しなきゃあかんです
だから この貧しい人々とかね
そういう助け必要な人々に何か与えるんです
でも その人は何もお返ししてくれませんよ
難民場なんとか言ってご飯配っても
そちらもじゃあお金あげますというとありえないでしょ
向こうは死にかけてるんだから
しかし それは素晴らしい行為なんです
それは与えるのみの行為の模擬なんです
でもそれで自分が人格が直るんです
すごくいい人間になるんです
だから ただいつでも与えては得るだけではダメです
時々与えるだけということもやってほしい
それから出家に布施をして
絶大な価値がある善悪の知識と真理を教えてもらう
出家っていうのはもう経済基盤がない生き方をしているんです
だからもう支えてあげなさいと
それであなた方にはもう絶対的な絶大な価値があるものを教えてくれるんだよ
だからその場合は全くもう与えるものほんのわずかで
得るものっていうのは
もう無料無制限で得るものは得られるんです
そういうことも勧めています
経典では はい で 徐々に欲を減らす生き方をするという
これも経典よくありますね
徐々に欲を減らすということは
やっぱりこのやっぱりこの適量ということで
どんどん減っていかなくちゃいけないんですね
何よりも満足 精神的な落ち着き
心の清らかさなどは有意義な価値としてそれを目指す
そういうこともやった方がいいというふうな
結局経典にまとめなんですね
以上は経典に出てくる内容の概略です
だから そういうところからこの今日の講義を作ったんです
で 経典の名前なんかたくさんありますからね
皆様の手元にあるっていうのは六来経という経典で
いくらかデータがあります
他はいくつかありますけど
ちょっと日本語訳とかなんとかないんです
はい これで終わり どうもありがとうございます
あの単純なシンプルな質問でいいんです
素朴な で 内容は単純ですけど
ちょっとあの 全部コンパクトにしたんだから
なんか難しいなという誤解するかもしれません
結局言ってることすごいシンプルなんです
はい えーと あの よくあのー
喫茶店とか行くと あとコンビニとか行くと
そのレジの横にあの ちょっと募金箱があったりして
まあ小銭で重いなと思ったら入れたりするんですけど
あとは街頭で募金とかもよくやってますけど
そういうものっていうのは
なんかまあわりかし小銭っていうか
別にまああったらいいけど
別にまああげてもいいやぐらいのものあげて
結構それで良いことをしたとか
なんかそういう ちょっとなんか変な優越感みたいなのもあるのかもしれないけど
そういうちょっといいことしたなぐらいの気持ちがあるんで
別にそれで損したとかっていうことは全然思わないんですけど
あの そういうなんかまあ
まあ人に与えるっていう場合に
特に仏教とかちょっと勉強すると
そういう布施っていうのはありがたいことだとかって知識が頭に入りますから
なんとなくやっぱそういうちょっと募金とかすることもいいことだなっていうふうに思うんですけど
あの まあそれが果たして人格の向上とかに関係するのかなっていうのはよくわからない
まあ大体そういう募金活動の場合は
この最後に説明した この得ることを期待しないで与えることなんですけど
だってあの難民にね 何かあげたんだからって
そちらからこちらにご褒美来るわけじゃないでしょうし
与えるのみでいいですけど
それは素晴らしいことなんですけど
もうちょっとそこもちょっと変えた方がいいと思います
例えばちょっと小銭が入って
自分がじゃあポーンと募金箱に入れちゃう
それはどちらかというと優越感があるかもしれませんだけど
処分するというカテゴリーにも入らないわけでもないんです
だから処分するって場合は相手をバカにしているんです
世界はゴミ箱だと思っているんです
だったらもうもう 7円あるんだから
これはじゃあもう一度 100円も入れましょうと
あの 100円が自分の人格向上になるんです
私はそういうふうにやるんで
時々そうやって処分感覚で何かちょうだいと言われる場合は
まあいい それじゃなくて
これも持っていってくださいと
何かプラスアルファにするんです
でないと 自分にとってはいいことをしたことになりません
どうせいらんものはその人が持っていきたいし
あ それでよかった よく役に立ちますとか
その気持ちはないんです
で 前 私のところにいくつかの家具がありまして
一つマッサージ機とかね
こういうのもらったもんですけどね
かなり高いもので それは全部どこかに調べて送ったんですけど
そちらから この何といいますか
この手紙来るんですよ
もうこういうものをいただいたありがとうございますと
これね えらい気持ち悪くなっちゃったんです
なぜかというと 別に私はその老人の方々を助けてあげましょうと
そんな大胆なことではなくて
自分が引っ越しするんだから
もういろんなものはいらなくなったんですから
明らかに処分なんです
でも 買ったものはほとんど新品もので
だからもうお金払ってゴミに出すよりは
必要なところに何かないのかと
森さんにも頼んでね まあ調べてもらったんですけど
でも私はいいことをしてって
その気持ちは全く毛頭ないし
だからそこで向こう側からお礼状が来たところで
えらく気持ち悪くなったんですね
なんてことするんでしょうかと
自分が だから何かプラスアルファにしたならばね
まあその条件ではそれはプラスアルファはできないし
だからもう 7円お釣りがあって
まあこれはまあ入れちゃうだったらもうちょっと 50円玉でも 100円玉でも一緒に入れた方が
あの与えるのみの行為になります
その時は本当にいいことをしたんだという喜びを感じられる
はい はい 与えてはいるっていう感覚ですけども
その与えるっていうのは受け取る側の価値っていうことで
だから佐藤さんがさっき言ったみたいに
受け取る相手がどういうふうな感覚で受け取るかっていうのがわからないものを与える時には
その与えた時のその自分がそのこれをやりましたっていう感覚がはっきりしないですよね
例えば目の前で受け取る人がいて
喜ぶ人がいればはっきりしてて
これを与えてっていうのがはっきりするんですけども
だからそういうのはなんかどうかですね
えらい怠け思考で聞こえるんですよ
だから生きるということは大変なことですごい真剣に理性の人生だから
仏教で言っているのはね
私はこれ理性の人ってはっきり書いてあったんです
だからよく理性を使わないと
だから与えたんですけど
役に立ってることかわからへんぞとかで与えたことになってない
ただ処分してるだけ だから私には何が与えられるのかと
まず具体的に理解して
それがどこで最大限に機能するのかと
その研究もする必要あるんですよ
だからただこの怠け思考で聞くのはそういうわけなんです
そこはアウトして質問するでしょ
だからその必要成り立たないんです
例えば自分がどこかのいろいろな今くじとかいろいろあるでしょうね
そこでくじ券もらっちゃって
それで女性のカバンを
なんて言いますか 当選しましたと
それでこれは女性のカバンだから
あの人にあげるぞと言ったっても
それでは最大限に有効かどうかわからない
このカバンなら誰に最大限に有効な有効かと考えて
自分が付き合ってる女でなくても
まあ友達がいるんですけど
女性のとこであげられないと男がいる
そういう人にあげる その人が自分の友達にあげれば
それを最大限に 自分が付き合ってる女なんか
こんなくだらぬものいらんという可能性あるでしょうね
そこら辺は自分には計算できるでしょ
で カバンもらっちゃった
それは自分が付き合ってる人じゃなくて
あいつにはいろいろこんなものじゃなくていっぱいあるんだから
あの太郎君も女の子と付き合ってるんですけど
あいつはもう貧乏で何もあげてないでお金
もしかすると女のお金で食べてるでしょうと
だからあいつにあげましょうということで
その女の人ではなくて
その場合もあの男の人にあげるんです
女の人にあげたら女の人喜びますよ
しかし 最大限ではないんです
機能は そこで男にはお前の女にあげなさいよと言ったら
あのカバンが最大限に機能してるんです
そういうやり方なんです
そちらの理性というものが必要でしょ
だから決して実践不可能なことを言ってるわけじゃないんですよ
私は 人がどう感じるかわからないでしょうとか
とんでも話 とんでもない話なんです
これは単なる与える世界だからね
必要かないかということはね
わかります  徳って欲じゃないんですか？徳って欲じゃないんですか
徳っていうのは欲じゃないんですよ
どう言えばいいんですかね
特に反対で負けるっていうことなんでしょうね
負けたり損したりするのもよくもうかっこ悪いでしょうね
だからうまく生きてるんだというね
ことなんです いかがでしょうか
またありますか  すいません
余羅田毅さんの本で 自分がその幼稚園だが
小さい時にカトリックの幼稚園に行っていて
そこでその先生にとか
神父さんなんかにいいことするときは人に知られないようにやりなさいというふうに言われたというふうに書いて
そのことをえらく自分の原体験というか
いうふうに書いてたんですけど
あの まあ何かその 例えば施しというか
人に何か与えるとかっていう場合の場合に
そういう人に知られないようにというか
やるとか 例えば芦田央氏なんじゃないですけど
そういう匿名で募金をしたりとか
匿名でお布施をするとか
そういう人に知られないようにするっていうのは
なんかそういうポイントとして
仏教的に考えた場合 ポイントとして成り立つんでしょうか
それは成り立たないんですね
そういう人々は分離してシステムを考えているんです
俗世間と神の世界というね
全く分離して仏教は分離してない
すべて一緒に考えているんです
それで この俗世間では損得なことがあって
それがあまり良くないという立場があります
神の世界が正しくて 世の中で我々商売して儲かったりする
それはもう悪魔の世界というのを分離しているんです
仏教はそう分離してないんです
日常生活で損得するのは当たり前のことで
避けられませんよと それを正しくやりなさいと
ブッダがすごい具体的な生き方を語っているんです
その過程で プロセスで悟りもありますよと
だから最初から徳ばっかり捨てていて
最後に最高な徳を得られるという徳の道なんです
分離してないんです 細菌
体に病気をするさせる細菌があって
それを殺して健康的になるという考え方じゃないんです
だから この俗世間の生き方で商売やったり
いろんなことをしたりしてやりとりありますが
それは道徳ではございませんと
それで別にいいことをすると
それはみんなに知られて知られない方がいいんだという話なんですね
だからみんなに知られるか知られないかということは
問題になるのは だから知られてほしいと与える場合は
それは純粋な与えじゃないんです
だいたいもうキリスト教にしたっても
純粋に与えるものは徳だと思っているんです
でも 合論ない世界でそんなこと言ったって何の意味もないんですけどね
与える必要あるんだったら神がやっちゃえばいいでしょうに
なんで自分がやらなくちゃいけないかっていうこともあるでしょうね
だからそれでも彼らにも現実を否定できませんだからやっぱり貧しい人々
ない人々には与えなさいよと
それで俺がこれぐらいのことをやったぞと宣伝しちゃうと
もうただの商売であると
そうすると悪の世界であると
日常生活的なというふうな考え方があるんだから
この商売感覚を切るために
宣伝機能を切るために内緒で与えなさいと
左手であげるものは 右手には知らせてはいけないという聖書にありますからね
文章はそれは使ったりはするんです
それは別に悪い言葉じゃないんで
言葉自体はね だから宣伝目的でやるものは純粋な与えではないんだよというぐらいの話で
しかし 与えた人を宣伝することは仏教を認めるんです
与えた人を宣言宣伝する
与えた人が自分を宣言するんじゃなくて
あの人はこれぐらいいいことをしたんだよと
あの人もこれぐらいのいいことをしたんだよと
みんな喜ぶと それでみんなの心にも喜びの波動を与えてあげるんです
それで読んだ人はなるほど
すごいことをやる人もいるもんだなとかね
喜び感じるでしょうね
それで徳がすごくよく広げるんです
だから私 何々ものがこれこれぐらいいいことしまったよと自分で宣伝が
あの何か日本で誰かいたでしょ
あの そういうやり方では良くないということなんです
逆に別の人々は 笹川さんがこんなこともやってる人だよと
あんた方知らないのかというならば
それは本物のあれな仏教的なことなんです
だからそちらのポイントは
この期待せず与えるポイントだけなんですね
期待せず与える場合は
まあ人に言うなよぐらいの話で
... まあ仏教的にはそんなにも大胆なことじゃないんです
だいたい仏教の世界というのは
だいたい互いによく知っている世界なんです
言ってはいけないと言っているのは
この瞑想の経験だけなんですね
それが言っちゃうとすごい危険なことになるし
インチキどもたちが仏教を破壊するしね
試しよくないんだから
俺がこうこうなっている
こうこうなっているといくらでも言えるでしょうに
それで一般人を騙しちゃうでしょ
だからそれは仏教を純粋に守りたいし
人の道を決して壊したくはないし
だからそんなのは言うなよと
それでも仲間同士では言い合ったりはする
なぜかというと それでお互いアドバイスを受けたりして
自分自分たちがそれで成長するんだから
例えば養老先生がいっぱいいいことをして
それは日本で知られていると
他の人々もそれに巻き込まれるでしょ
巻き込まれて その人々もいいことをすることになるんです
誰も知らないんだったらもう自分だけの特効薬だと優越感だけで終わっちゃうんです
やっぱり自分だけの救済ではないんです
だから 他の人々も救済させなくちゃいけないんです